Pessing! This is how I sound over the game, in game audio of BALATRO. Not to be confused
with BALATRO because I can't read. Apparently the card in the middle is actually an A in
the game's title, so it's BALATRO, okay? BALATRO.
Ah! Jeez. The delay on when I click go live is astronomical these days, I don't know what's
going on. Pessing! Dear reflings, please type 1 on your keyboard to show that we're
synced. How was your royal flush? Terrible. I'm baking a loaf of bread because I've got
some issues. Okay, no see that was fast. I think it just takes a couple of minutes for
the dang thing to register. Right, so what I said when I click go live, but I don't think
you heard it, is the game isn't called BALATRO, the game is called BALATRO because it's an
A, the A's in the thumbnail is an A, and I've been calling it BALATRO because I've been
removing the A and the T because of the scots. I'm like, I'll be playing BALATRO, BALATRO,
any BALATRO players? That's her absolute shawls behaviour. Good morning, good evening, good
afternoon, I am none other than your huh, stranny cuddles. Now, originally on the agendination
it was Elden Ring, but unfortunately I have absolutely disastrous news, it's not disastrous,
it's not a big deal. I was up working after my beloved Mercy stream, if you guys did not
know, I got to stream yesterday with Mercy playing Goose game, and it was the worst type
or choice, or choice together if you want to say both words at the same time as I just
did there. It was the worst choice because Mercy has very severe motion sickness and
that camera angle would not stop spinning the entire gameplay, so poor Mercy had to
go, or I sent her off, I wasn't happy with it. But the long and short, if you missed
the Goose game with Mercy and you don't have time to watch the VOD, Mercy did a big scary
burp and both of us recognised what that burp meant and it meant her digestive tract was
getting ready to reverse due to her motion sickness, yeah like her motion sickness when
playing video games, but we had an absolutely fantastic time being Goose that one point
she was controlling me as a Goose, her controller input was moving me, so every time I tried
to move, I was pushing against Mercy's command, I was like who's hypnotising who you are?
That's not allowed, literally the reverse scrawny, that's not allowed. But it was an
absolutely lovely collab, I'm so happy. I also, the girls have a beautiful Uno collab
coming out next year, oh my god spoilers for next week's schedule, oh my god you're spoiling,
originally I was going to participate in the Uno, but I'm not anymore because originally
Shibi was, but then Shibi had a job, so Shibi couldn't do it, but then Shibi quit her job,
like an absolute boss, like a beast. So now she has time to do it and she's going balls to the
wall with streams which I'm so happy, I'm so glad for her success, special thank you to anyone who
has supported any of the girls, you are enabling them to level up in real life, unironically.
Because Shibi literally, speaking of poker, if you didn't know Balatro is about poker,
Shibi literally said I'm all in on Vehler, she's put all of her stonks in Vehler, so thank you to
anyone who is making such a risk worthwhile, whether that's clipping, whether that's interacting
with her posts, watching her vods because it generates money if you watch vods because there's
advertisements on them I think, I don't know, I'll need to check, I actually, so from the behind
the scenes, you can tell YouTube to place ads during a stream, but I say no no no no, I'll place
some YouTube, wink wink, I'll totally put ads down in the middle of a stream, I do not put ads
down in the middle of a stream, I don't like it. The VOD, I believe should play an ad at the start
and the end of the VOD, I don't know if it does it in the middle, I'll need to check that out
because I've been a knot in Ellie and I've not been checking. You did great with the girls,
oh stop it, stop it, did you do a royal flush, no, so I had to take, I was up working but I've got
two more ASMR collabs agreed upon, I sent away two scripts, I actually need to make an ASMR script
for Mercy because I came up with a really good YouTube ASMR roleplay script for Mercy that I
absolutely adore, so I need to work on that shortly. So originally it was going to be Elden Ring in a
12 hour stream but I'm like, I need to cook for these girls, I need to, I'm needing to tell them
there's possibility, there's a talent manager maybe coming in but I'm going to ask the girls
what they actually want because there's no point in getting this chicken, she's a Vtuber herself,
she does her own content, she has experience doing projects, that kind of thing, it's a she,
it's a she before anyone fucking says I'm in, they're replying to my email, you're not having
access to my daughters, okay. Kings Lupus, thank you for becoming a member, I appreciate it.
After two hours of Chucky Balattro, we are going to be doing membership ASMR and then I believe
that is my membership debt paid for the week, yarg. Originally next week I was going to watch the
Barbie movie, I might switch it out for something else and I need to decide on what series we're
watching during RuneScape which I'll be curious, I do have a cup of tea, can you hear my little
thingies against it? It might be good to delay the ER to let people enjoy the DLC first but you've
got 24 hours to enjoy because I'm doing endurance tomorrow so as the girls are on their own for the
next like week, I'm playing with my refunds in that opening shot case, I'm playing with my
refunds for a week straight, we're doing an endurance a week straight, we're joining my
games and you're all holding my hand, okay. I don't want to hear about anything from the girls,
sorry, yous are on your own, go speak to management, that isn't me okay, go speak to someone else
because I ain't me, I ain't me, I can't, that book is closed, I ain't talking to yous, I'm no interested.
Literally, oh you've got plans, don't care, don't care, not opening your DM, if I don't see it,
it's not a problem, kidding, I love you girls but it's been a long time coming that I could
play with my refunds again okay, so you're gonna have to, you're gonna have to give me some time
because the refunds have waited a very long time for me and it's been bloody nice being back so
do forgive me girls if any of you are lurking, I need my replin, my replin, my replin, please
don't die, you know like if it was like a little Sims 2 bar instead of environment because, or maybe
instead of hygiene actually, I've not had to shower in a couple of days, normally I shower at least
like every other day but recently, you know my little refill and bar is low and after endurance,
how you call it, endurance, Elden Ring, I will, I'll be good to go, okay, so right, I'm going to
drip drip drip, my honey tea, I have my script writing, my membership script writing stream
is coming up, I ask permission for the girls if they're comfortable with me writing stuff
live for them and I got a few thumbs up, I've got a few requests not to do everything which I said
no that's not, the reality isn't going to be like I'll do it all at once but that script writing
screen stream is most likely going to be roughly two hours, there'll be a bootstrip script, sorry
there'll be a boot script, there'll possibly be two ASMR collabs with other VTubers,
I actually need to write my one-on-one collab with the VLR girls because I've not actually done
that part yet, like I need to do my like, I want to do like, so for Emi, I want to do big sister
and little sister tease you with Tingles ASMR, I think that would be adorable, AC,
I wanted to do like, I actually want to see AC in a school uniform, that sounds really weird,
I'm sorry I said that out loud, that was an insane thought, I wanted to like AC to be like a weird,
not bully but maybe like some sort of like high school roleplay with me and AC together,
maybe like one of those like after school clubs and we were forced to come together to do it and
then like, AC grabs your phone and she notices that you watch ASMR and then like, well and we're
all just kind of like, well we either do nothing for an hour or we could just muck around and do
ASMR on each other, you want Gairu AC? Gairu? Yeah, Shibi, Shibi is my other half, I wouldn't,
what would I want to do with her if she's my other half?
What would we do? Maybe a blindfold type of roleplay would fit Shibi very well,
if you didn't know, I try and do the theme of the person I'm collabing with, I've actually
got a really good few themes, I did win with them, not to ruin it, I don't think she actually
streams at this time so she's not even gonna be awake, I did a hexa collab and at the end of it
we hypnotise you to mind break you and to only watching us and I thought that was really cute
but before you like, do you have to put a disclaimer, it's not it's not real like actual
induction or anything like that so I don't think there's going to be necessarily any induction
needed at all for it, sorry any disclaimer needed at all for it, also can we get one minute
silence for the cheek clap ASMR video, oh that's my best fucking audio, oh actually that's another
thing, I am editing my third audio that goes up like the day, I need to edit it after the ASMR
history, I've got like a lot of things I need to catch up on, I need to like send stuff to editors
and I need to do my own stuff and I need to do this and do that and look we're getting there,
we're getting there, per mimosa, per mimosa for one, she was the first person that accepted a
ASMR collab with me and sent me her lines and she must fucking look on her subscription list and be
like ah she's streaming for 12 hours again, yeah that sounds about right, per mimosa she has been
waiting patiently, I am going to try and finish everyone's that is on standby, today that is my
job, let me let me finish more of my tea, for Azura, I think double heartbeat would go crazy with me
and Azura and a kind of sleep aid rest between us type of audio, I think that would go incredibly
hard with Azura just from how naturally soothing her voice is, I would absolutely love to do something
like that and we kind of like do tingles as you, the listener fall asleep, maybe you're feeling a
bit rough and you're just eating some extra TLC, I think that would be good with Azura,
so me and Mercy are actually kind, we're not quite the same side of the coin with each other
so I want to hypnotize to Mind Break, she wants to break you in because you're resistant to her
so we've got a bit of a similarity, a bit of a lurking theme, I'm wondering if I could get
Mercy into a hypno, maybe Mercy comes to me because she needs help to hypnotize Senpai
because you're being extra resistant because resistant, if you didn't know resistant hypnosis
is actually quite big where it's like me the person speaking like acknowledges that you're
resistant so well but then you use phrases such as sooner or later you're going to break like
resistant, there's no point in resisting like this kind of stuff, any chance for ace marvin
yes please um yes those are my one-on-one collabs I actually used to do with girls,
Emmer's is about to go on holiday so I'm not gonna ask for that until she's over the hedge,
do you remember that movie?
Strony is a Bork confirmed, oh my god the Bork scared me so much but then they introduced Seven
and Nine and then oh the Bork turned the Bork turned me on so much, I love Seven of Nine
she my favorite, Penpal's about to suffer, Strony you using, well there's a bit of a
no, Strony uses a refland to demonstrate how to mind break someone so Mercy can, oh
see Mercy wouldn't necessarily, um actually no that's really good, fuck you I'm stealing that
I am literally copying paste in that and putting it in my little notes this gorge
this is for uh what's your name, Mercy Collab, Emi Collab is big, it is wee sister, oh sorry
little sister you can't, I don't think I could put wee sister because everyone would be like is she
passing, Emi Collab is little sister and big sister tingle you mercilessly, I see I want some
sort of like feral bratty, oh bratty school girl that makes much more sense bratty school, no it
doesn't make sense because it's supposed to be after school class, after school club goes wrong
and goes tingley, goes ASMR, sexual, it doesn't but you know what I mean, um Azura double heartbeat
sleep aid tingle layers reassurance for bad day nice and simple and then sheepsters
who goes there blindfolded um blindfolded tingle experience with
30 different tingles how about that 30 different tingles a little cheeky challenge
okay that is now in my notes discord so I can hold myself accountable to such dastardly acts
the girls are comfortable if I write certain scripts on stream and we can certainly do explore
those kind of things so you can quite literally get me and my VTuber companion to say what you
want to hear so don't be don't be afraid to um
mm-hmm right bilateral I don't know who the game dev is
shall we get into it I know how poker works I do not know how oh
hello there my name is Jimbo I'm here to help you learn to play
your goal is to earn chips and defeat the enemy blind
this here is a small blind you only need to score 300 chips to beat it
select the small blind to start the round okay thank you Jimbo
oh you earned chips by playing poker hands
each poker hand earns a base amount of chips multiplied by some multi
see your poker hands in the run info area along with other info what about your current turn
run info straight flush oh my god actually tells you how to play
what the fuck is a high card right straight flush um I understand a straight flush four of a
kind full house is three and two yeah flush is flush is five cards that share the same suit
I'm gonna have to keep that in mind you know that straight straight five cards in a row consecutive
ranks but not the same three of a kind yes with two other unscorable cards that's fine
two pairs that's possible and you can throw away the fifth oh so you have to play five a pair
just simply throw away three but what the heck is if the plate hand is not any of the above hands
only the highest ranked card scores wow okay okay I'm not
okay cards also earn you some chips hover to hover over to see
now select now select up to five cards to play and press play hand uh we've got
have we even got anything we've got a double here uh can I not do anything with these trips
they're not a triple but whatever we'll learn oh shit I've just wasted them okay we're learning
relax I'm learning okay let's try that again you can also discard up to five selected cards
to try and make it an even stronger hand try it all right that's a double there eight seven six five
so what we need I don't know the two yous can go I guess
hey carefully you only have limited numbers of hands and discards per round
earn 300 chips before you run out of hands good luck okay right uh eight seven six five oh piss
I thought we had it uh we're doing all right we've got two pairs and then we'll throw away the three
I guess play hand
yeah don't have to play five oh you don't have to play five I'm learning oh god I've got two more
hands to play double see these are two doubles here oh I've also got that as well but kings are
kings are higher double than double five so just play hand play ball
oh oh oh jeez I'm almost gonna lose we have five discards
um honestly I'm tempted to throw like all of these away
and go for the oh what does this mean doubles two doubles and then just throw that in there for
the hell of it why no two doubles they should okay that's perfectly fine more than adequate more
than adequate that was a good throw away there we go we did it 300 I know it was very terrible
gameplay but uh cash out we got three dollars nicely done now that you are flush with cash
you can buy some new cards from the shop well but try buying this handsome devil
buy this is one of the 150 jokers that you can add to your run every joker does something different
this one adds four plus multiplier to every hand you play be picky you can only carry five joker
cards at a time okay now buy the other card from the show enhances two selected cards
oh wait ain't that not banged in the Isaac card this tired card is a consumable
this will only enhance your playing cards hold on to it you can you can carry up to two consumable
cards at a time if you save up enough you can buy voucher voucher oh voucher vouchers passively
upgrade your brand okay we want vouchers and vouchers are restocked after you defeat the boss
blind a persona reference so uh and check out both of the booster packs in every shop they're
fully goodies oh i like the i like how they pop out i don't know how the development team is
for this but um it's such like a i'm i'm enjoying like we pixel games at the moment honestly i'm
going nuts for them i finally watched the legend of zelda trailer reveal why did they have to make
it so cartoony it's just one guy for the dev team shot up he came up with all of this that's fantastic
um select the big bind will earn some cash or tap or skip it to get a tag each tag has a unique
effect but keep an eye on the boss wind it has the ability you'll it has an ability you'll need
to plan around discard two random cards pair hand played oh wow okay and if you beat it then
the anti goes up and all blinds become harder ups the ante okay beat ante eight to win now
choose your path great well gives one dollar pair unused discard this one we'll give two
what sure let's go for it i have no idea what i'm doing yeah it's by one canadian when you get
more cards remember you can rearrange the jokers trigger an order from left to right but we only
have one and make sure you use your consumables select after two cards in your hand and press use
on the territory to enhance them enhances two selected cards to multiply okay we have two jacks
already so we can use them as a pair wow they're scored now okay i mean we can submit two doubles
right off the bat why do we want to throw away though maybe just throw away the two for now
yeah shot we need four four hundred and fifty dollars okay oh that three was useless though
oh wait we already did it oh my god wait how much money i got for this
three dollars cash out for seven dollars feels good man
Uranus level up not discovered level up two pair multiplier i like that buy and use so the planets
upgrade
the effectiveness of them okay we definitely want planets um i did convert up to no i don't know
that does no we'll just go next i will keep my money's um next round yes please okay hook line
and sinker discard two random cards pair hand plate discard two random cards wait so even if i purposely
put in is it gonna randomly take away two that i put down
are you squinting me right now miss the last two streams good to be back
thank you for the 50 my goodness thank you so much that's okay jeez louise thank you
oh shit what happened i completely did not put it wait we won oh it's in oh it's been
attention we won we defeated the boss thank you thank you again for the 50 that's a lot i'm
gonna uh this is two short streams today two hours worth of baltro and i've already yapped
my head off for 20 minutes classic scrawny um and then two hours of membership asmar i have no
idea what to do for it i'll just do whatever you want i'll do anything you want baby just let me
get to it right what are these the joker gains one multiplier pair consecutive hand played without
a scoring that is far too intricate for me this joker gains a multiplier for each card sold
that does nothing for me so what's about her permanently gain one discard each round
the um that looks good
hmm
if i'm if i'm doing terrible that could come in clutch
yeah wasteful redeemed oh that's not a good thing to be though
advanced joker and i'm so much an ASMR today i'm glad to tell you um i don't want to
choose one up to the three playing cards at a deck um no i don't i don't see
right we need 800 bucks what's blind upgrade flush by three levels orbital tag upgrade flush by
wait do i want to skip so i get that or if i skip i'm not allowed that
huh wait a minute i didn't watch enough gameplay in order to understand what happens if i skip
oh maybe just play every round uh are you making the clapping ASMR somewhere else
if you skip you get that reward wait but that's an insane upgrade flush by three flush oh wait no
flush is the hard one that i'll never get so there's no point in doing that
um oh very bad hand very very bad hand indeed we've got a triple but that's it
oh no we've got a full house pardon me my apologies we have a full house i couldn't see it
couldn't see the forest for the trees my apologies full house full house
um let's see what we're at eight times oh that's a big number okay we're already halfway there and
that was our first hand we still got three hands uh we have actually
um we've got a mini flush going on here
did i just do a high card for now yeah can only do a high card
heart's flush oh my god oh thank god you said that oh i could have upgraded the flush but didn't
because i didn't think it was possible
okay maybe i should have got that flush level three because that's actually pretty good
uh kosher crackers thank you for becoming a member see you in the member stream and
literally two minus two hours thank you so much for the support it helps me achieve my goals oh
my i have some good news about my shorts editor her name is a rissa and she seems very happy
to work with me and isn't weirded out by my terrible humor um uh she has already finished a
short so um my channel might be getting more shorts no not a rissa a rissa with an a not a
rissa from overwatch a rissa from overwatch is not editing my shorts her name is a rissa um
and she's already edited one and she's like so cool i'm like is it okay if i can do a batch
payment because that's easier on me and wow what's it no i don't know what she is
plus five hand size but reduces one takes away a round
wait about five extra cards in hand but reduces just by one round i feel like if i have five extra
cards i might understand in this right i will have five extra cards in my hand
the music makes me think of rissa rain yeah a rissa with an a that yeah this seems good sorry
let me learn from my mistakes that make this game i don't i'm a really fuss for the deck stuff
what is a straight what's the straight uh or straight is one two three four five that's so specific
and it's so rare i'm like is there a point in me buying this if it's so rare and before it happens
in if i skip it gives a mega arcana plaque for free choose two of the five tarot caught in that
you've lost me you've lost me 12 is an insane multiplayer oh
oh
10 9 a straight level one yeah whoa this joker is insane like i've even got a triple here
uh maybe should have gone for a full house what's more stronger straight or full house
okay we're already halfway there wow um we can do a full house with twos
and then a double with sixes full house oh full house looks good you have a street street what
where oh my god i'm an idiot i do have a street so street is stronger
i mean we won oh we did not win yet holy moly moly wait what's the straight five four three
no i don't well ruined it now have no let's just do a full house again and we've got it okay
we've got it if i do the full house sorry run info for help isn't it the worst right straight
consecutive rank all the same straight four of a kind is higher a full house is actually higher
wow okay then a flush of the same suit a straight is wait what oh a straight flush and then a straight
is uh god this terminology is making my head spin what do you mean i have to learn one two three
four five six seven eight nine nine new terminologies that's five too many right and then it goes
straight and then it goes three oh no it doesn't go straight sugar because like that says 40 times
three oh wait because it upgraded pairs oh okay okay okay i'm gonna have to i can't believe it i
should have maybe played this a bit more offline but hey hope we did it we hand size minus one what do
you mean minus oh but it reduces every round oh sugar okay i understand a bit more we got cash
we got six dollars i hear the cogs turning very slowly this joker gains when any booster pack
skipped like these
two plus chips for every remaining card in the deck
chips what's the check that two plus chips for every remaining card in the deck
a hundred chips extra that seems tiny chips are blue the blue area yeah oh this is this good then
multi is the red number wait that looks good then yeah that does look good hold on get that bad boy
in there right i i need to do this in order or something so apply four multiplier to everyone
and then add the blue so cute hearing you say oh sugar oh sugar i'm trying not to throw too much
because i feel like i do it like every sentence and i'm like hmm shouldn't be doing that thank you
broly legend for the tips actually wait this becomes useless it's gonna become useless so
uh this joker gains a multiplier when you skip booster packs and these are booster packs
uh i'm not really interested in tarot card choose to
spectral cards oh i don't even have enough is spectral cards my planetarium ones
right okay we can't do anything more this joker gains when you skip booster pack
hmm let me learn from my mistakes okay this is my first run choose your next uh bind up the ante
raises all blinds refreshes blinds all diamond cards are debuffed so i can't i don't get anything
out of using them okay that's bad and not fun i have five discards
wow i'm a bit perplexed on what i'm supposed to do
diamond card fans see them diamond don't give points but it still holds their value
like if i played two pairs
40 times three and then what time 40 times seven
i don't know the two tens would be more valuable would they it's still 40 times
but the multiplier wouldn't apply scores no chips and all abilities are disabled on it so
i should do double sevens with a queen
i need to learn from my mistakes so i'm sorry if this is bad
i need to learn from my mistakes so debuff doesn't apply but the two sevens do apply
700 a thousand okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay double we did level up pairs
so i'm quite happy to just keep doing shout out to all my pairs god that's an old name
uh yeah right we all we leveled up pairs see pairs level two here and so i'm quite happy
to do the pairs right yeah another thousand okay we did it we did it we did it this uh i'm gonna
have to sell this when it doesn't give me anything because i assume it's gonna actually reduce
i made some two dollars one dollar one interest pair five bucks wait the okay okay great
voucher tarot cards appear no i don't
the first hand of round is if the first hand of round six destroy and create a spectral card
if first hand of round has only one card add a permanent copy to deck and draw it no i like the
dna for it though that's pretty cool hmm you want a celestial pack ah there is okay yoinkers hello
level up a full house level up a straight and well straight flush is so rare to get though
four of a kind that seems so rare to achieve i don't want to like pick the like most rarest
thing because it's never gonna happen you've been getting a lot of full houses okay i trust we will
upgrade air fill house oh that did go up by quite a juicy bit okay we want celestial packs not any
of this nonsense tarot cards appear two times more frequently in the shop that is nothing for
me so don't even pretend you're helpful gives a free oh wait i want celestial not spectral okay
oh my god you guys are so good at poker have you have you guys been gambling
have you are you guys gamble lords i'm getting nervous right we've just upgraded full house
so let's give it a shot shall we
let's give it a cheeky shot what
okay let me let me upgrade full house because that's so good all my family plays as poker by
by proxy i'm cracked out on poker that's amazing okay right celestial celestial right what's going
on here eight plus multi if a card has a pair i don't have enough for both oh no i do have enough
for 30 chips for each remaining discard huh i want to do let me do celestial
let's see maybe if there's earth again no there's not
could level up pairs shout out to all my pairs um flush high card i've never used the i've
never even done high card urinus level up two pair i we do do two pair a bit when when it's not
looking that good um we don't really get straight much i think two pair urinus oh you didn't know
the planet's called urinus right let's do urinus let me make my mistakes if i'm making terrible
choices please bear with me as he's in the room because uh this is actually my first gameplay
i have watched people play it right if it contains a pair that seems pretty strong
but that is 30 chips though but that's tines eight multiplayer if i we do a pair though
tines eight multiplayer is big unless we sell that like right now
if we sell it to get the i think i think we're doing it i think we're selling it to get this bad
boy um right multiplier multiplier and then the chips come in and then the chips come in yeah
yeah next round yeah yeah look yeah yeah okay
uh it's okay to make mistakes mistakes and how we learn gives a free mega pack i couldn't
give a rat i need celestial packs right what are we looking at are you squinting
brian a bit late but i'm happy to be able to catch a stream
underscore love congrats on the editor uh thank you so much floss yes um i'll be actually able
to put up like shorts pretty semi recently oh god this is a terrible hand if i play a pair but i only
have one pair i think we're doing a discard i don't normally discard but give us okay
double pair double pair i'll take a shout out to all my pairs let's try it so what happens now
eleven eleven ten ten a hundred good multi four multi sixty eight wow
wow okay okay that was a good choice doing whatever we did
uh once you start getting multiple mullies rather than uh addictive additive then it starts to matter
oh no yeah i don't think we're actually gonna win venus level up three of a kind i wouldn't mind that
i don't need the tarot card one and two chance to create a tarot card when a booster putting up
i'm happy to buy news venus i think we just need to level up like the base pair stuff
and then it means no matter what we do we're getting like a massive um buff basically you haven't played
three of a kind shit ah it's three of a kind not full house oh all heart cards are debuffed right
okay technically that's three of a kind and then that becomes full house
50 times five is 250 65 times six is lake 36 okay so it's better to play
okay it's better to do that even though it's debuffed
full house is there okay yes i was just confirming i was like try to do numbers
really quickly i'm like hmm my brain actually doesn't know how to do numbers like this
especially in the morning for the wee bit math don't you think okay that was good
whoa we already did it whoa i got an achievement called anti up because the ante is now four
joker unlocked ooh so you get to unlock more things ante off achievement unlocked
Saturn level up astrae voucher one plus hand size i think well three and ten
oh we have enough for both read trigger all cards and final hand over and what does that mean
what does that mean i don't know what that means right we'll do hand size
um after me measuring my hands on that one foot stream or that in real life
oh no was that this room no it was an american sweet stream level up straight yeah sure whatever
well we'll just level up basic stuff you know yeah cheeky cheeky level up is what i mean
i can do 1000 calculations per second and they're all wrong you need to build up your
interest it means if you're gonna lose it doubles the value of that hand have i got it oh i don't
have enough ah well skip explained rerolls the boss blind all club cards are debuffed 10 000 though
oh no i'm getting nervous i don't know if we're gonna win
uh i see nothing
five four three two and i don't have a one our king jack 10 98 sugar
do do i play a double right if i play this pair and then use the rest to just throw away and reset the
oh that doesn't really seem like the best idea discard okay discard take get rid of that and get
rid of the nine and maybe we can either go high well okay okay okay okay all right let him get up let
him get up we've got an ace and two pairs level three that looks that looks good and then we'll
throw away one of the oh wait does someone say hearts no i don't have enough hearts okay uh i'll
throw away that in case we do end up getting hearts and um that's two pairs truly wait you have a
flush what's a flush what's a flush i do have five hearts i do i do oh i thought i didn't i checked
i checked if i didn't have a flush ah right king queen jack 10 9 what more could you ask for
oh i literally was like oh check if i have 10 eight five of the same but no i don't smile
uh exhausting to watch don't you just want to take out all your pent up frustration out on me
uh that's okay you can do it okay we got we got it we got we got it that's the main thing
played cards with hearts give a three multiplier hermit doubles money
choose one up to two joker cards
a joker for four bucks actually doesn't seem like a bad idea
a joker for two bucks doesn't seem for four bucks apologies
10 if the hand contains a flush the joker gains three chips per discarded club card that's so
specific
10 plus multiplier is big though
it's big but that if i discard a random club it'll give me three plus on the chip side
i mean
but that's 10 plus multiplier i pick the 10 okay thank you thank you you have influenced me right
all the multipliers go together multiplier multiplier multiplier and then chips and then chips okay next
round it rerolls the boss bane lane i i mean we've won with the debuff before so i don't see why
we would need to change it
trips check them
so throw away these
space space right surely that seems great fillers is much better than zero became
so discard
okay fill house let's go play hand play ball play hand
oh
oh i didn't make enough right okay okay okay
who's that six five four three two
yeah straight flush sure that looks correct and winnable winnable question mark winnable winnable
yeah okay we won we won straight flush we won
six thousand for that okay that was good that was good i like that i like it do it again do it again
very winnable straight flush in hand foggy
is it rare oh no oh celeste deals up this joker gains a multiply every time the playing card
a playing card is added to your deck that's uh a curious one
iron two dollars pair discarded if no discards are used by the end of the
no i'm a bit bye this joker gains multiply every time a playing card is added to your deck
is that cute maybe
uh
i feel like flush is so
the everlasting get you more money you add cards to your deck well buffalo deck you
haven't added any new cards oh so it doesn't count for me okay well do do celeste all pack then
what can we level up drum roll please uh full house
udonis mercuries just appear a flush four of a kind i don't really get that lot
i think full house we seem to get a lot so i'm a bit biased towards earth if i'm being honest
yeah that's a good that's a good buff i like that do that again do that again keep going
um all club cards are debuffed we can do it though we can do it
i've only got a dub a dub levy
this card oh wait sorry someone's saying i've got something you have a straight hold on
ace king queen joker 10 oh i knew i had a straight thank you no i already no sorry
sorry to make you stress there i clearly saw that i had a straight why yes of course aces
are high don't be silly of course aces are high i don't know how you didn't see that reflin you're so
silly sometimes that was only three thousand how many hands have i got free i do have a lot of
discards though have a pair five four three two six yeah
please yeah oh seven would have made it higher i under okay i'm starting to get i'm starting
to get it okay sorry my apologies my apologies seven would have made that higher in retrospect
however uh we only need three thousand more so i think we've got it in the back question mark
we can do a double and a double like that and then with the added extras
uh let's just three four three we'll just throw away the eight while we're at it
because yeah i know i'm doing wink wink i don't know i don't have a clue i'm doing
mr abic arbic abic one mr abic one thank you for becoming a member okay we made it we made it
goodness golly me even though i'm like nerfing myself i'm too powerful i'm having to like actually
immerse myself cash out six dollars don't mind me
eh does nothing
eh soon no one will be able to stop me does nothing neptune's back i'll just buy neptune
oh i can get neptune and another celestial the hanged man oh my gosh i can fly around the room
and isek feels good man uh yeah i think i'll do neptune and celestial because i don't know what
does nothing does but yeah you have to buy it 10 times to unlock some grove that's extortionate
right we'll do well if i get straight flush we're in the money for that one right let's do celestial
back
a pair a street a four of a kind a street
i feel like we've got straight more than a four of a kind
Saturn or Mars straight or four of uh some's a Saturn
10 times in this economy exactly street is what i do a lot okay thank you we're level three on
straight let's go where so be right next round i've only got two dollars on my person so i'm not
really sure gives a free spectral do not bother about spectral but thanks anyway uh i'm
i see a double bay i see a really weak double with these two that's so weak though
i think it might be a discard round one two three one two three four five you're out try again
no wait a minute that's not how it works is it
it
there we go there we go i thought i had to had to put up the queen there my apologies
i always like satin's satin's not clicking what's not clicking what's not clicking
okay we need 11
oh we're gonna need some multiplier jokers to come in because yeah we're not really rolling
and smoking six five four three so i don't have that have a jack double
yeah i think in two pairs well and then what try and get rid of this three down here as well
while i'm at it get rid of the three while we're at it get it out my out my face get out my way
i'm no i'm not playing with you you're too weak
i cannot do fast math in my head oh we did it okay we did it in two rounds that's not bad
i wouldn't mind like more multiplier jokers in place because
yeah i'm getting a bit going shakie oh
Uranus level up two pairs i play it so often i have enough for both i have enough for both
i love it here i love the economy in belt row that's so good i'm sorry bilateral
bilateral we love bilateral
what right a straight oh so you have a kind oh i'm thinking straight again
our flush daddy flushes often your anus is so back thank you
belt row goes hard it's too late for this game but generally your top row other than score in
the minimum points you need is a $25 for max interest your economy is super important in this
game ah you mean any hold on to my my money's and not spend at all but but i'm a woman that's
what we're supposed to do you tend to miss flushes straight would be better wait what you
tend i miss flushes so straight would be better right i trust you i trust you okay so i need to
hold money on my persons okay i will keep that in mind oh look it's the thing that's in Amy's
bedroom i remember when the bedroom creator came back with that and i was like what the
fuck is on the back of the room but uh it's like an actual thing next base edition shop
joker is free and becomes negative negative is one joker slot but that means i'm allowed
a six card is that no good
that's so powerful yeah the devil is actually ah yeah yeah uh it's like i already knew you were
going to say it like i said i'm on jokes your pair joker is negative
oh
does it mean like very very good if you're strong enough to skip
you already have a six joker slot oh i do and then this will give me a seventh
as long as the card is a negative but also for each okay fuck it we ball this is literally a
gamble game was gamble cards drawn face down after each hand is bro where's my hangman
does that mean what i think it means the cards are going to flip over on me so i'm getting a
piece of paper right now i'm not i'm not going in this blind okay the fish more like the fish
don't ever give me this mission again right okay
i see fuck all
okay i'm gonna have to ditch so we have an ace oh no pencil oh pencil please work with me
i don't have a pen oh i do have a pen i'm a weak fiver okay i'm gonna keep right we're gonna ditch
all you guys i know i do have a pair they're buying that leveled up we have an ace we have a 10
we have an eight and a seven surely this is gonna go well the new cards are drawn face down
i'll be shooting blind shut no way that's not even possible wait i can play this do i want to play it
i think you're fucked
did i just play this for points do not play the pair no no okay
you can use the shorthand discard good okay discard thank you thank you read thing
right we have an ace we have a jack we have a 10 an eight i have two sevens a five a three in a
two what is this hand look this is the worst i just want riddities honestly these are so weak
i think i want to go high and just get rid of all the low you know that
keep the sevens sevens are good
you can play less than you can play less than the five if i want to
you can dig for a flush i that's something throw the threes the five and twos but keep the sevens
okay it's not gonna be much of a shuffle that's my only
are you fucking fishing me i think i'm gonna have to play a double
i think i'm gonna have to do it so i've got an ace i've got a jack i've got a 10 i've got an eight
and i've got six yeah i think this is what i'm gonna throw away the six just because i don't want low
um boy thank you for the five gifted memberships congrats to the people who caught it with your
face in your face uh yegachad you've got lots of discards left i know but i get nervous i'm not
gonna do it in time look at her getting addicted to gamble i've become the very thing i swore to destroy
i've got oh fuck it i need to earn some points fuck it ace jack 10 and eight
fuck it fuck it
oh puss that was
hello
is this probability
hah wouldn't it be oh i can't even get a royal flush that's not how it works
um it's sorted by rank okay so we know these are lower than eight and these are higher than
that use the sort button that's already at rank you can sort by suit
oh no
wait so that can give me a three suit no but you can't do that
oh man now it's a puzzle game bruv bruv
that was doing so well on this run but i don't think we're gonna make it you can discard the
face down cards wait they'll come back the cards will come back viewable i don't want to get rid
of these because they seem high discard all the face done
okay
it's very likely this is a king right if it's not we've got a double joker
is that how probability works
male's camera thank you for coming to member i appreciate it this come on
unbless we just played mega safe and do two ace and two pair that'll give me what 5k again
i'm needing a christmas miracle
no gamba all right gamba right what did i do ace king queen
oh that's not what i did at all right i can put down that card because i know for a fact either
way i've covered the thing so this has to be a king surely this is a king
oh we did it we did it gamba paid off we did it probability oh wait we only got 4k for that
that was so big though
that was so big
um i don't know if we're winning this one i think wait hold on rank if i do it by rank
these are all high again so the probability of a double riko thank you for the five gifted
memberships congrats to those who caught it with your face in your face that's totally not the
blue joker is coughing up blood at the moment is it this one
uh am i hemorrhaging the blue joker's um help yeah congrats on the memory thank you again
riko and boy for all the gifted memberships right if i do it by rank these two are whoa
what if you want to like number them out the wazoo oh then you can about this
uh i don't i'm not even looking right 10 and ace there's no way the odds are the game
the odds are the game actually can't give me another
flush
um can it give me a flush do we just gamble again but we're not making enough we're only
getting 5k per round i've got two more hands
oh math jumpscare honestly uh you know what we're playing a gamba game it's very unlikely
we're going to win this round so you we might as well go all in
how
how i'm not lucky like this i mean we're not going to make it because we don't have
um
math jumpscare this is impossible i think i'm just gonna have to discard
i don't want to discard the high though if i discard oh i don't want to discard the high
this is most likely a double nine here so these are useless but i don't want to take them out of
my deck clearly there's another straight there can there be there can't be oh
fuck it did we just do this and see if we get any like thingies i don't think we can win we're
we're so blind discard everything and pray yolo yolo i think just send it what we got
oh we could add a triple nine oh no i don't have enough good jokers for unfortunately
that was a good run though for that was a good run best hand that was so good
oh no were you bluffing too sometimes that is so good defeated by the fish yeah definitely
not wanting to go against the fish again that was rough right new run blue deck unlocked discover
at least 20 items from your collection one plus hand every round joker unlocked defeat a boss
blind in one hand without using any discards um i'm not sure i'm that good reach anti level
joker turret planet and spectral cards may appear multiple times um i had pretty bad luck with
jokers okay okay uh what what is this i'll just do basic red deck i don't oh seeded run i thought
this had speed run i was like steady on it i don't think i can do it speed thank you for making it
hard for me to work smile i didn't say anything bad i've never even said anything bad this stream
thank you really legend for the tip i've never even said anything bad this stream i've been good
doubles your money like that you can hold right i definitely need to hold on to my money a bit
better so gender norms you need a back off right now ace jack ten nine what two pairs i feel like
because it's like just the start we can kind of you know piss arse about i think
yeah we've got like three rounds we can we can play low games okay we can play
low games like low rounds it's not it is not um bad right nine ten jack i wouldn't mind getting a king
gonna be honest if we get a king
unless we get an eight then it would be a lower flush but
fuck it give me a hand uh uh
i'm not gonna have to play pairs shut up to all my pairs but the main thing was no economy yeah
you want to try and win in one hand because each time gives you an extra oh
keep an eight in case of an eight yeah i totally kept the eight what you're talking about what do
you mean you didn't see it it just walked away i know i should probably go for a king but
you know what it's the first round i think we win by default just because of how low the the
blind is it's so low like it's we can't really lose this famous last words famous last words we
can't lose this uh wait wait can i just keep playing pairs or am i actually gonna lose in the first
round please don't that's that's actually embarrassing please don't actually make me lose in the first
round okay it's fine it's fine we're here we're here um well just get rid of all these then
it's fine it's fine yeah there's see look we got a little triple oh we got a little full house
moment please see it's fine no no i i don't think i can lose on this the very first level i think
it's hard to lose there's three good weeks high straight high flush medium full house
yeah you guys are kind of i'm gonna lie reeflings i didn't realize your past time
was gambling gambling's quite bad didn't didn't you know gamble bad
see that hand size helps i don't want it
i'm gonna go and keep my economy
skip playing double your money no that's not useless for me
then save your money save your money i may quickly make a cup of tea after we lose this one
because there's no way i'm gonna be smart enough to actually win i refuse to believe
i refuse right what we got
after losing many hours to this game i found sticking to one type of hand and destroying cars
so don't match it with the devil arcana or other means it's a good way to help build a
consistent strategy for collector jokers are jokers locked for me thank you jobon
brian we love betting on mortgage no stroney i'll catch up later glad you liked my idea for the
mercy collab earlier go conquer big no we're not conquering big gang but thank you job
no go job no go job no go that sounds like an ace of martyr job
thank you for the 20 um yes thank you for your patience for watching me play this for the first
time i did watch another streamer play it for like two hours and i was like yeah yeah i can play
this game on stream mihu as soon as i hit go live completely forget all of the terminology
because you guys are like yeah flush are straight and all that and i'm like
i remember i remember that a phil house is going to do a three and a double four of a kind is well
four of a kind straight flush i need to get straight and flush flush is all the same but
straight flush is all the same in the same suit okay i just need to get my head right about flush
and straight flush the toilet because it's all the same color that's how i'm going to remember it
no i don't care if that's disgusting flush the toilet because it's all the same color
and straight numbers okay that's how i'll remember it when you guys are talking
that's how i'm going to remember it this is where i make my stand oh no keep the eight
people say keep the eight so i'll keep the eight
we've got a duplicate right we'll play the double oh wait i don't have a joker in place i may actually
lose this what so i just bend these i'll just bend these ones okay it's fine oh that's what i
wanted to see right what can we do we can do ten jack king queen ace let's go
flush like my whole face flushes with red when i see you okay that's probably a nicer way to see it
than a flush the toilet because it's all the same color half that man that's probably a nicer way to
put it uh wait again more on core on core on core straight on core it feels good man
okay i'll take it hopefully we can get a joker for multipliers in the shop because the the joker
cards are kind of definitely maker break the jokers are maker break one and two no don't care
um this joker gains three multi with any booster pack that skipped
i mean i skip booster packs or is this a booster pack even oh i guess that's a booster pack so it
doesn't count okay we'll just do celestia molest sorry um my brain just wanted to run
right a straight flush is when it's on in the same suit which is so rare three of a kind
isn't that rare four of a kind i think three of a kind oh wait but am i actually gonna do three of
a kind normally if i've got three of a kind i'm able to do a full house
intrusive thoughts are coming out i can't believe it hi stroney belcher is my favorite game hope you
like it i am so sorry for the gameplay you're about to witness i can only apologize it's my four of a
kind is also super hard three is more realistic yeah i um i'm biased towards venus because it's so
unlike straight flush is so unlikely and four of a kind i i don't think i've actually played one
four of a kind yet um so we'll just upgrade the most likely we've still got ten dollars in hand
so surely that means my economy is good right right all heart cards are debuffed i don't think
we're gonna do this we don't have a joker on the playing field yet we don't have one joker oh there's
our triple oh baby a triple we're gonna throw away these and play three of a kind
i'm gonna throw these away play three of a kind
right we're already halfway there let them get up let them get up let them get up right we've got
let's go that's how it works right we already did it okay we didn't even need a joker but i do
want a joker i do okay i really would like a joker please okay that was good that was good
spectral cards can shape your deck to increase the likelihood of four of a kind oh i don't know you
could do that uh the cards are in my favor and before i have a really good lucky seed then i
mess it up i went nine for that one two dollars interest for every five dollars in my thingy i
get an extra dollar that's good don't feel bad enjoy watching you learn this is a game where it gets
easier the longer you play or at least you understand it better oh thank you for your patience jubo no
i can't say this reptiles fast thank you for the tip again yes and thank you everyone for your
patience i really enjoy being i get full house often
i get full house often yankers i get full house often please
yes no i'm actually really thankful for it because like i don't get a lot of time to play well this
sense well now that i'm a vtuber i get plenty of time to play games for the first time but before i
didn't hardly have every time like to like just be late i don't want spectral packs we'll play
like i just never had time for it but now i have like all the time to like like look at these games
and be like you know what i'm actually interested in playing that game this game that game right i've
got eight now i want to throw a nine away that seems a bit harsh i'm a better throw at the
pair away but i feel like the nine's just randomly sitting there
what what do my my trusted advisors the reeflings advise
your hard work paid off by the way have you seen that one banana game that's trending on stream
no someone says keep the name the message after it chuck the nine wait what's the banana game
Danny to look it up you could also keep the clubs oh you're right
surely we will score another club
i'm gonna regret doing the club route you know that i'm gonna regret them can i just play that
it's only gonna give me what like less than a hundred if i play that
if i play the just play the two pairs okay okay okay okay we'll play the two pairs
and we will throw away the three i'm gonna try and throw away the four and whatever hand i get
next as well because it ain't whatever we tried to do any time it's no happening so might as well
try and get rid of the low so we can have a hand fuller we have a triple and we've got the freaking
buff of it i don't have a double no yeah okay and then we'll just throw away the six and the four
yeah that seems right yeah yeah i'm getting MLG right we do need a joker though i would
very much like a joker joker joker if you'd like to show up a decent joker um we do have
three discards we have a double of a we do not have any suits coming into play i think i'm happy
to just throw those away wow
wow i mean might as well just throw those away because we've got a queen to follow up right after
don't mind if i do don't mind oh wait it's a full house
wait ace is standing is anything for a full house i'm oh wait all i had to do is play double queen
i'm sorry i'm but we did it we won i'm so sorry i apologize wow we got three extra dollars because
of how much money on my hand i'm sorry but we did it anyway that's the main thing oh my gosh
oh my god the game is tempting me so hard right now i'm so i'm so tempted to go out
the inner inner women was it do they call it retail therapy the retail therapy is going
hard right now please please let me cannot buy them all please please reeflings let me buy all the
four of them please for me i've been such a good streamer i've been streaming everything
no don't say no to me say please i said please
very concentrate on a specific hand are you serious oh come on let me go for it it's retail
therapy right i'm going for it i've been a good girl sorry but most removed like oh i need to
break streaming so stressful uh no i need to play more with the reeflings they need to hold my hand
through games fuck off move aside i need to keep streaming okay so let's still pack right full house
high card i never play high card three of a kind or full house full house if we invest in earth
then full house offers more than what a base three of a kind can offer anyway because you're
getting extra two thingies in it
a fucking earth card desune
oh no i've only got nine so i'm only gonna get one dollar the fact i don't even have a joker yet
is shocking create up to two jokers must have room create but does it mean use the two jokers
i might have to do that if it means it gives me two jokers i think we might have to
do
yeah skip skip okay right give us these jokers because we need it
whoa one of them's turned off are you okay
oh person 20 multiplier if the hand contains uh three of a kind okay
50 chips if the plate is a pair yeah we needed something of this nature so maybe we'll go for
trip check on boys um triple triple triple we've got a duble of a but it's two i don't want such a
low duble of a it might not be obvious but you can sell jokers if you don't want them and i'll
sell them once we get like better things to replace them with not three of a kind
only if you play three cards or less wouldn't that be three of a kind then i'm so sorry
contains a pair a pair contains three of a kind it's three or less cards so a pair in a single
card would also work to activate you
do i discard you can play a pair playing a pair of two with one of them debuffed is like
rough though i think i'm gonna throw all these away play the twos oh no you say play the twos
do it let's just play the twos see the power okay reef flings i'll see the power we're playing
three so that should activate we're debuffed on the two debuff right that was the weakest thing
i have ever witnessed in the game said aye that's fine
whoa so if i do this i win
whoa jokers are maker break holy crap jokers are maker break
okay and we get a little bonus dollar as well yes we did so we got eight payout that's good
oh my god the game is tempting me stop it what is this one consumable slot no i don't really mess
with that high card i never play a flush oh it takes me just under 15 it takes me just under
15 so i'll miss out the three dollar bonus but i want to i want to try the buffoon pack
choose one up to two jokers oh fuck it we ballin right let me get this one and then we'll try the
buffoon as well oh my tummy hurt am i experiencing a hunger i might be adds double the rank of the
hand to multi to do jog oil change karate eat candy ruminate earn four dollars if poker hand
is a two-payer poker hand changes at the end not sure about that one add is double the value
the left one's pretty good i am inclined to also want to pick the left one the fist okay please
fist me okay thank you i'm sorry um and we will get two dollars per every round played
and just to add double the rank on the lowest so that's a multiplier so we're going to have
the multipliers together and then the chips that side um upgrade high card by three levels
but i don't play high card i never play high card
i feel like high card is like a hail me unless wait hold on hold on
that 20 multiplier would come into play if i played an ace like an ace on its own
hold on a minute hold on a minute this might actually be worth it if i'm not mistaken
this 20 multiplier as well as high card it won't help with the pair of joker as it won't scale
very long yeah but no chips oh true right let's focus on duplicates and trips okay we'll focus on
doubles and trips thank you for your your um right we already have a double ace if i play double
ace and throw away the five with it add the double to the lowest rank held in hand to the
multiplier so it has to be a two which is fine i'll take a two uh right we'll get rid of the five
just to clear a few things up in the hand don't forget to check your run info why yes of course
so two pairs is what my strongest contender but the multiplier isn't actually that big
oh sorry my apologies four full house is my biggest earner we are starting to level up
quite nicely i'm enjoying it uh i think we'll throw away the five um
yeah sorry this multiplier comes in very strongly if i do the five option skipping around is very
impactful because not only do you lose money but you also lose your chance at seeing the shop as well
oh okay okay maybe that's why i was like hardly see any jokers um jay to the torn card do you have
a kind as your hail mary full of grace someone sent me um something on marsh mallow and it's like
hail strongy my comments with you what how we've already won that was just one goal and we get an
extra two dollars and remaining we got eight for that that's fantastic oh no i'm getting four of a
kind i'd never get a chance to play four of a kind though what are you play aces give 20 oh wow
four multiplier as well as 20 chips
oh i'd buy the spectral pack and nothing else are you spectral pack player i'm only celestial
him in the planet booster still leaves you at 10 so i would still get double
you're right i'm going to do celestial pack and joker this joker if he comes in correctly
so that's a multiplier so i want it to be in front of this guy
and then that's a little thing on top
wow okay okay let's let's see what we've got in here
we have a high card i don't play a straight flush i don't and a straight straight definitely straight
but a straight flush is next to impossible odds i'll take a straight though
right let's do it let's see what we're up against
3000 or gives a mega arcane pack which i am not fussed for personally three aces is the ultimate
hand for you now speaking of aces i got nothing
double nine audit is it like is it valuable enough or just throw all these away
would double nine be valuable enough
pair yeah i'm like honestly and then i'll throw away the two just so it's not in the way
let's see what let's see let's see what happens if i do just double nine what kind of monies do we get
okay why it's so big so if i get to play an ace it also a double ace well we'll do double 10 and
then that's what's done already
we have made pairs so OP honestly
literally have made pairs so OP we don't even have to do anything
oh this is so good
oh we got extra four bucks as well four and then remaining hands
ah yes okay so that so if i'd managed to do it in one i get three max dollars and if i keep a lot more money on me i get more
okay okay okay okay i'm getting tempted though joker tarot planet and spectral cards can appear multiple times
don't care one in four chance for a holographic
but it can fail
if it fails i waste three bucks but i'll still be but i'll make it back naturally complete in the round
so is it really gambling is it really gamble if i don't actually lose out on the money in the next round
the wheel mathematically never go for the wheel but technically i make it back by default so it's not
really gambling it's not really gambling
whoa it put on the best one
it put on the best one streamer lock streamer lock streamer lock identified
play only one hat okay i can throw a ton of stuff away though
wait i make 2000 with a low pair anyway
okay let's throw all this i saw away i just need an ace that's it move one
move one that's it that's all we had to do even though the game said play one hand
easy peasy leaven squeezy
wow 6000 for double aces
wow
oh my goodness we got five bucks for that and we got our three bucks back so our gamble heck and
paid off on that we're now in the 23 what's this v-roll boss blind one time but it's cost
to do it right what are you hundred chips if played hand contains a three of a kind
that's actually not bad for our build but we are going for pair a pair yeah we are going for
a pair should have upgraded the pairs i don't really go for flushes maybe there's a pair in here
gamble for the pair what's in here let me see a pair so i want to level up pair now don't i
buy or three of a kind pair or three of a kind
pair or three of a kind pairs i know the pairs are just so op you want all the mercuries got it
loud and clear loud and clear mercuries are the way it go right right right right what are you a
flush i don't even need you anymore do i know now this one does have my interest because there may
be situations where a triple will come up i'm tempted i'm tempted arcane for easy win choose
choose one of the three tarot cards to be used might as well seems good right okay
that's our five jokers which i'm happy with so if it's a pair i get 50 if it's three of a kind i
get 100 so these actually conflict a little bit maybe that wasn't the wisest idea
oh dear maybe i shouldn't have done that you know what you live in your learn let's go next
you live in your learn 5000 create creates two jokers to choose from though oh that's juicy
uh three of a kind gives you 150 because both of the jokers apply oh wait i don't want new jokers then
uh you don't have room yes i would have to sell so let's not do that let's not skip around
we'll also get three bonus for how much we won we won already did we win already
play did we get 5000 just we do because we got 6000 last time
seven thousand when we won first hand okay okay i like this game this is getting
ye this is getting jesse look we got an extra six dollars bonus i was gonna skip that as well
thank goodness i didn't choose one of the playing cards to add to your dick re-triggers all the cards
i don't really quite comprehend at random he can apply a multi depending on what time he's putting
re-triggers good with your joker whenever the fire rises you know i feel like i would have
to sell that one though for him yes that makes sense to sell him in order of a higher molly
yeah okay get rid of him add you you crazy card you i'll pop you right there because
these are both chips and these are mullies oh wait does he need to go in front of him
because he does chips as well right what is a jumbo saleth pack i am very happy to see you
whatever you are it just means there's a lot in it mercury um i'm going for you i'm all in on mercury
yep all for you baby
oh i doubled it up twice that's fantastic okay order doesn't matter with these particular
jokers okay the blank gives a dollar pair unused discard this run will give 29 bucks
i get 29 dollars with a skip this
take the 29 and run that's worth it okay don't have to tell oh wait but i don't have a shop
but that's okay because cards played previously this ante are debuffed so just do aces once
ah wait no
my aces don't count what do i do uh it's just two aces that are due discard for pairs right
i'll go for high pairs i know that's one there but
discard again
discard and triangle for higher pairs up here that seems like the smartest thing i can do
yeah that
i want another ace to appear
not me being able to do a royal flush oh sorry that's a straight my apologies
do i get actually you know what get rid of this ace that doesn't work and then when the double ace
comes through that'll be better so this isn't a lose lose this is still a good move it gets rid
of all these cards and it gives me a higher chance to roll an ace that isn't affected no
no wait no yep discard the other ace just discard the ace and use a regular ace
just keep the ace level three straight is good though yeah
better to discard the two
oh i'm conflicted on what to do i guess straight doesn't work with your jokers though but i do have
that no there's straight is good oh fuck it sorry i don't know if i'm gonna mess this up i don't
know if i should get rid of this ace and then in hopes for an ace that isn't debuffed though
straight doesn't work with any of my jokers though
mm-hmm
mate i'm gonna do this to clear my hand i have three more yeah i do have three more turns i'm
doing this to clear the hand on purpose okay on purpose i am clearing the hand i got five thousand
that was decent if i can just get there see boom what do i get if i do double ace
uh-huh let them numbers keep going up baby uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
wow okay it worked it worked it worked it worked it worked it worked and you got any
doubt or wait so if i have 45 in my pocket how much bonus that yet oh max of five which is 25
dollars still low um planet cards appear two times more frequently yes i want to upgrade this shiz
out of my uh planet cards so yes i will take you what i do with you planet merchant redeemed yes
what a okay i don't put it anymore try a death card select two cards convert the left into the
right that is confusing but i will take your word for it uh choose one up to three tarot cards
to use immediately maybe if we get the wheel of fortune because there's no point in being less
than 25 so i'm down for the wheel of fortune gamble will we try that tarot is so good let's see open
huh
creates up to two random playa planet cards must have room for a planet card
i don't think a planet card means what i think it means
compare up to three selected cards to hearts i mean i could do a straight well i don't want
a straight flush i've got triple there use the death card now convert two cards
select two cards convert the left card into what the right card is
oh no planet no not yet
astronomy didn't have another stream in 10 minutes oh my god i have to do membership
somewhere right we're gonna lose anyway but it's fine use the high priestess okay
we got earth for it a full house but we don't even i mean sure use it why not
it's kind of it's not here nor there you never know i might come in clutch in case we completely
i complete i'm getting too sucked into this game so what are you pick up to three playing cards to
add to your deck let's just explore we've got the money to explore let's explore
if i play the nine of hearts it gives me nine chips sure why not
enhances one selected card into a steel card sure why not get get on get on in and you come
i've spent hours on this game the chariot's good sure deck now contains an extra nine
oh my gosh i don't know i want extra aces 11 000 we're getting a bit we're getting a bit
hasty gives a free mega buffoon pack choose two of the four joker cards
three plus hand size next round oh no my enemy the fish i think that's our big downfall unfortunately
no worries you can use death and chariot in the middle of a run to get ace cards
shop is better
doesn't feel long at all because you get so absorbed play chariot right now
i can't use that i must be able to use it in the game
playing pierce fish is pretty easy okay right so i play yeah i'm to play it surely surely i have
to play it because i don't know what should choose two of my joker pack yeah well i shake
hand honestly right only use get the fuck out you're wasting my time
right user oh go wait have i got a heart no i don't want wait no i don't want to do hearts
wait use death on what on the ace time to use death on this
this is use can't use it select two cards and convert the left card into the right card
wait that would make it a king then on the ace in the three wait like that and then death use on
three convert your three to an ace you can drag cards around what i don't even know you can do that
so then use on three
use on three yeah now use this use on three
wow okay that is big enhance is one card okay wait can i enhance it too
oh i can't wait you enhance i enhance you yay i've got a steel card what does it do
eleven chips and a multiplier world this card stays in hand
oh you do we hold back i didn't know what she did i thought it was a good thing
you now have five aces in the deck stop wait that's so good i want to convert everything into aces
now ten thousand oh come on we were 100 chips no 92 chips less i just play this get out of the way
just play this you could have enhanced and then copied yes we are learning we are learning
but we did it that's the main thing we got our cheeky bonus five dollars as well so
planetarium upgrades are getting pretty pretty on the house um convert increase the rank of
two selected cards the phone now choose one of up to the cards
increase the rank of up to two selected cards by one can i put that on aces strength on
and turn kings into aces as well stop i'm gonna cream is that real
that re-roll could upgrade kings to aces okay i am learning i am tempted to re-roll honestly
if we if going below 25 doesn't count then okay plow no i don't play high cards that was rubbish
the joker gains three trips pair discarded diet that nah right okay that was always the money
we are not rolling again uh no i do not need that or do i do i need that for the fish draw
cards face down after each hand played i need that for the next round to ensure i win
shouldn't need to skip you only play pairs so no it's not worth it okay right if i have a king
i can upgrade it oh yeah if i have a king no three of a king bum bum bum
nice and easy straight thief for king right away play hand
bum bum bum bum bum and then i'll upgrade a king if i get a king in my inventory my inventory
are my inventory didi you're in my laboratory
i've got an ace so throw everything else away i need a king or an ace and then
oh well that's it already i think so yeah that's it we did it okay we are we actually on a winning
streak hold on a minute the the membership asmar is delayed we're actually on a win streak here
give me a second let me cook let me cook we actually might be winning this somehow
i actually don't know how the game like what the end in game is is that the ante is eight i think
eleven dollars feels good man what we got all cards are considered face cards what does that
even mean can dig for kings with the fish she's getting addicted me addicted you have to be eight
boss fights beating ante eight is the end so we're already halfway through
should be able to uh with when all the kings become aces you can one shot give me mercury
mercury mercury shit
maybe i'll just put it on saturn then and then a straight would be a hill mary
oh dear well we tried yeah well straight's getting pretty big um
some jokers care about face cards it's a buff face cards don't matter with my jokers though
she's hooked the fish is on the hook so if i refresh it doesn't refresh the celestia pack
i'll just use this right i'm not afraid re-rolls don't don't do anything right level up my king
level up my king as long as i roll the fucking king right increase the rank of a card
increase the rank of up to two selected cards by one so do it on the eight as well while i'm at it
you can do two kings so get rid of all this you can upgrade two kings discard from more kings yes sir
say no more right okay slight kings strength use on the kings please
oh it's a good day down in philadelphia are we looking good discard the law three aces let's go
let's go oh show me what we're getting maybe can we do it in one can we do it in one
oh
shit what i really don't want to lose against the fish seven aces are now in a deck though
discard for pairs i don't want to discard the high though because they could be a
are you sure discard the face up everyone saying discard for pairs
i'm worried about them being aces and like throwing that away
i don't know if i discard the lower cards right let me discard these ones
and then that pushes me to most likely have high
can i test it right i'm going to test what we get if i do tens okay because ten is safe
let me just test it out let me see how it goes what happens if i do tens
a classic ten five thousand okay so we've won if i do nine i have two more rounds so please
don't worry if i'm completely messing up i have two more rounds i think we've done it and we've
got past the fish fish v fish who's gonna win i think i win yes i win right get right take that
take that shove your blind up your arse okay we did it that's the main thing that's the most
important thing is that we did it okay the fish is dead and we got five bucks i'll take it right
what we're looking at enhances two selected cards to lucky cards one and five chance to
multiplier one plus hand size i don't think i want to give anything up
the misprint is so valuable i don't want to give them up
one make it
zal thank you for becoming a member i promise i'm doing the membership
ASMR shortly i'm addicted okay i'm addicted
so this makes it less hard but one less hand
hmm i don't want to give up any of my jokers i want to buy in your joker slot
i'm gonna buy this because that looks all right less hard you can turn aces into lucky aces yes
can't we hunt buffoon packs for molly jokers or buffoon packs have molly joker
buy the buffoon pack okay i'm taking your advice buy that what happens here
uh-huh um 100 chips take away five for every hand played gain three dollars of
sale value 100 buy the fin don't buy 100 chips i've played no and no these are rubbish
well i don't want that thanks for the waste of money rubbish don't do that again
yeah i would like to upgrade my
choose one of three playing cards to add to the deck can you give me an ace for no particular reason
man
oh
pack for more aces yeah dad just ignore this and then
can't add the jack on the right or skip purple jack is good what do you do
creates a tar card when discarded
um
take the purple jack okay i listen to my music sorry re-roll
well that was shite i thought i was gonna re-roll the packs right i need to remember it doesn't
re-roll the packs chips for each remaining card and deck no right okay let's go next let's go next
tar free the tarot cards and the real tarot cards include tar
20k next base edition shop joker has a free foil inside but i don't even know if i want to
take it so i'm not interested so my king
no i upgraded one king but one king acts like an ace now enhances two selected cards to lucky car
okay actually that's like a really big gamble for that one right let's get rid of you because
these are offering me nothing these are offering me nothing okay just like that and then apply the
tarot card to these aces for the hell of it and then we'll see what happens whoa they're
tattered now yeah let's go play hands
is the card gonna do a re-animation if i win the
odds oh no how good your beat is
i'm gonna have to upgrade mercury if i'm wanting to keep up with how big these um
blinds are getting lucky didn't proc but next time next time okay i'll just throw the jacks i think
they're gonna be fine they are worn out that's what makes them lucky oh you got 20 plus multiplier
from them oh i did not see oh i'm gonna start lagging behind if i don't get some upgrades
that took me three three rounds to get
i'm gonna have to start spending at the shop the shop's gonna have to start giving me the goods
because that was quite a few attempts my economy is high so that's giving me the extra five every
time which is good not gonna lie it is the first girl's addicted to gamble he's the most
i'm probably more than one free reroll in the shop yeah bloody like that wouldn't
know i don't want to reduce my hand size but oh if i would wait hold on hear me out if i reduce
my hand size by one we still are only rolling for aces and we can still discard five at a time
and if the ante is less it means i don't need to get as much at the moment which is what i'm kind of
needing oh that's not hand side that's hands numbers that i can play oh no i don't like that then
no sorry i don't like that can i get an ace i get a cheeky ace ace ace don't be shy give me a
fucking ace wow another jack
if the card is held at the end of the round i will get a tarot wow
ten chips three dollars with the card no i don't need it like that
yeah i think i'm going with jack purple again the four is good as well four chips
i don't go for one and four though my everything's on ace because of my ace card
we're yeah here if i play aces i get insane like i'm uh i'm not gonna try and
wait are you telling me to do math the purple jack is a tarot if discarded
no if it's held in my hand creates a tarot as well yeah
is it a poly what are you saying is it a polychrome glassed four are you memeing or is that real
is that a real attribute to this game or am i being frigging it's read strawny read ten right jack
of clubs ten plus three dollars if this card is held in your hand at the end of the round creates
a tarot card when discarded however wait so they conflict i already have a purple seal on a jack
they conflict if i hold on to it i get money if i discard it i get a tarot just take the purple
where i'm listening to you so i'm getting i'm getting all confuggled i'm no smart enough for this
right if this is shit and doesn't give me an ace i'm just gonna skip right
oh you know what i'm sick he is oh it's so pretty though oh my god it's perilous and
so the jacks wear the correct choices for you can boost another two aces i want to but i ain't
giving oh yeah sorry right we're going next i don't want my economy to go any lower i'm at 26
i'm pushing the the boundaries initial cards and booster parts in the next shop are free
i mean i have fine economy so i'm not desperate for that kind of gamble
what am i looking at here can i do a double ten
can i do double ten for the heck of it and then i'll throw away this four i just want to see what
happens i don't i don't i don't really know what's happening let me just do it a little funsies just
for funsies okay discard it oh
sorry
my apologies
um sorry about that old chap i got a little carried away there sorry a little carried away
i thought it was like a we a reward okay i'm just a discard purple purple on site will be
annihilated i understand purple on site will be annihilated i will do purple's bidding
wow i'm actually getting very weak i have two more rounds like i can do it but i'm actually
starting to get a bit i'm getting a bit weak i'm getting a bit nervous i'm getting a bit shaky
it's all going downhill she's moving too fast i don't i thought we could do it but like i need
mercury a step up i need this like random joker a step up oh well it gave me a 16 multi so how
can i complain um i'm needing like maybe another joker space if it would offer me such a thing i'm
needing to utilize tarot cards she says is she uh played the purple instead of freaking throwing it
away each king gives a multi nah wait well each king held well i don't have it level up for the
cane i can't play it i don't want you celestial pack mercury mercury mercury fuck okay we're not doing
high card three of the canes i think it's three of the canes because of our um and our jokers
and all that it's three of the canes venus works yeah mars is four of the canes couldn't care right
next round we
i'm getting nervous i'm getting nervous but i no repeat hand types this round what does that mean
i can only play one pair
oh no this can't be wait let me go back to the shop i want to retry i'm sorry i should have
bought the booster packs let me go back to the shop please i'm just a dumb streamer
please i have reeflings to feed right throw the throw that away throw all this shit away
right what happens if i throw you away discard yes create tarot cards when discarded
what are you giving me destroy up to two selected cards what does that mean
for free destroy these two
yeah destroy them only pair once make it count
send out the deck destroy means permanent remove from the deck okay that's good then
because i don't want these low
or it's permanent yeah use it okay use i just want
okay
i really need you to step up crazy joker man okay
and then i'll throw this nine away while i'm at it yeah
yeah we're on the same page
40 000 i've never made 40 000 before
hmm oh no
oh you're getting kicked out the window like right now
there's a flush now just hunt for a three kind of ace oh you have to troll this is not true
say it so maybe if i can get this tarot card to up an upgrade one a full house should
i just play the full house mum mum mum mum mum yeah i mean they're level five it's not like
it's bad queen over mommies jack and then i'll discard this
in the next round yeah okay let me learn from my mistakes if i'm making terrible decisions
i promise i'm doing members ace more very shortly i'm so sorry i'm addicted
what was that seven though oh we're not gonna make we're not gonna make every
plane so just throw them all away let me just throw the lower side away hand will not score no
repeated hands well good thing i'm throwing it away
ah what are you can bear up to three selected cards to diamonds okay okay i'll take that i
will absolutely take that you become a diamond you become a diamond you become a diamond just
for the hell of it okay go okay okay okay one two three four five flush play hand
okay what are we looking at baby what are we looking at what are we looking at what are we
looking at
no no we've no got it we tried so hard we tried so hard but in the end it didn't even matter
hey i can't even do that i can maybe do a triple ace if i'm not blessed in this life
can't do it play a three of any kind well it was a bloody good run though
it was a bloody good run it was we tried our best we did we did sire we did we
tried our best we got pretty far in in the game don't get me wrong uh but we couldn't do it
we couldn't come back from the yeah 2000 oh not even 50% jeez lol time for us to shuffle off and
try again yes if anyone wanted to try and win at that seed it's s s s jv2 bd
that was freaking good though the flush not having that 20 really hurt yeah
eh we tried maybe one more round i'm supposed to be doing asmr like right now i'm supposed to do
asmr like 20 minutes ago have fun with a member stream yes i'm gonna be a big girl and i'm gonna
do the member stream but please do not be surprised if you see this game pop up again uh as uh stream
that was thoroughly enjoyable card shuffling asmr do it in an hour should i round it i mean
if i go make a cup of tea maybe we've got like another 40 minutes and we just delay the asmr
for an hour like 40 minutes yeah maybe maybe i'm a little too bad okay i'm gonna go make a cup of
tea we'll play one more round okay and then i'll do the asmr i look like this is the focus right
and look this is the 3d o that i'm tapping like i promise i'll do the asmr i promise i promise i'm
not addicted i'm a wee bit addicted but just give me give me four minutes because i need to boil
my weekend okay i'll be right back
are you squiddling me right now
so
are you squid mirroring
you
Are you squiddling me right now?
How about one more time?
Wait, eight, seven, six, five, four.
Oh, it's cool.
Ten, nine, eight, seven, eight.
I see diamonds.
Surely I'll get another diamond.
No, I won't!
Shit, I kind of want a diamond.
Um...
These are so big, but fuck it, I want a diamond.
Give me one.
Yes, one, two, three, four, five.
Lovely.
How much we getting?
We're getting two free jokers out of this as well.
Double ace, double king.
Done.
Easy peasy lemon squeezy.
I'm eating my chicken nipples.
Well, there you go.
We are a bit poor, but so is reals cost less.
Wait!
Oh, no!
Oh, no.
It overrids the other one we could have got.
I want to reset the run.
I'm going to reset.
I didn't know I did that in your run.
Yeah.
I didn't realise it did that.
Okay.
One joker slot minus a hand.
Oh, okay.
We didn't even do anything though.
We didn't even achieve anything.
Right.
If I skip this one,
and then go into this one.
Yes.
Jeez.
Sorry, I'm a bit slow.
Right.
We can actually do a wee baby straight right here.
Why not?
Oh, my God.
This is delicious.
Wait, I'll just go around.
It's very hard to lose at this stage.
I'll go with duple b.
Okay.
I think we're going to have to get rid of all this.
There we go.
That's what I'm looking for.
I can't just get rid of that.
Okay.
I'm confident in the lower rounds because I'm like,
it's hard to lose in the lower rounds
unless you have like devious luck.
Oh.
No, sorry.
The voucher is worth it.
One extra hand size.
Yeah.
Worth.
I'm keeping it.
It's mine.
Next round.
Let's go.
Oh.
The blind was actually reducing it.
So I've just made it neutral now.
Oh, my free joker.
Why am I like this?
Why was I born this way?
Why can I only retain one piece of information at a time?
Why?
The average human can retain like seven pieces of information
at any moment.
Me?
One.
That restart.
Unironically.
Right.
Fuck it.
We're restarting.
I want to win.
Let me reset.
Let's try it again.
Three rolls the next shot.
Yeah.
No, that's fine.
Let's go.
We need to play perfectly
or we might not as well play at all.
I'm getting rid of all that and just doing trips.
Oh, wow.
Full house.
Don't mind if I do.
Okay.
Good.
What are you doing?
Mm-hmm.
I'll take you.
That looks good to me.
That looks good to you.
Cuttlefish memory.
Goldfish memory.
Oh, I'm way worse.
Seriously.
Mm.
Something else must be your other sex.
I just think of refluence for the rest.
Right.
I'm happy with that.
I'm going to plan it up,
which will help me in later game stuff.
Redeem.
Okay, good.
Okay, I think I'm going to kick in again.
This is delicious.
Mm-hmm.
That won't get access to the shop until after all of this.
But it's a free joker.
Surely I won't forget about the joker.
All hearts are debuffed.
That's a lot of hearts.
I'm not going to lie.
If I had a king,
we actually could have done a straight flush there.
Mm-hmm.
Get rid of all of you.
I have three discards, which is fine.
Um...
Full house?
Full house.
Yes, full house.
Right.
Uh, doubles?
I'll take it.
I'll throw away this eight,
because I can't do anything with it.
Oh, I'm going to see...
Sorry.
Ugh.
Um...
We'll get rid of the two,
because it doesn't do anything for me.
But it's here.
Thank you very much, we fling.
Um...
Well, we have 400.
We've still got enough free runs.
I am...
Let's just clear this deck up a bit.
I'm not really wanting that.
Two joker.
Let's do...
Oh, two...
Oh, well.
That doesn't count, so it's not actually debuffed.
Bless you.
He's on high.
Salute.
Wait, you're still here?
Look.
I'm sorry.
We're redirecting into Ezra.
I know it was supposed to be a small stream day.
I'm addicted.
Okay, I admit it.
I have a problem.
Stage one is admitting you have a problem.
Does it mean you actually have to fix the problem instantly?
No, it does not mean that.
What are you?
Please.
Right.
Retrigger each played.
Yoink for free.
What are you?
Permanently gain a hand each round.
Mmm.
But my pair...
Multiplier is also a hollow.
Get in my belly.
Right now.
Let's go.
I'll see if I can get this.
That would be good to get the pick up.
One extra thingy.
It would be free.
It would be free and we have no economy.
It would be free, but we'd have no economy.
It's holographic.
Next based edition Joker is free and comes holographic.
It's free and comes holographic.
Are you addicted to Boutro or Strewn?
What if I said both?
Did you get the free Joker?
I did.
The free Joker is retriggered each played lower card.
And it's called hack.
What an interesting name.
And then I have Sly Joker, which is a holographic.
So he has 10 multi on pairs.
So I think we're already doing the pairs.
We went from gambling bad to gambling addiction in three days.
It's so jover.
The reward is $3 plus or a holographic for free.
Our economy is so low.
I'm needing to build the economy, I think.
By the way, hollow is flat multi, not tied to a pair.
All right then.
All right, you've sold me.
You've sold me.
All right.
Oh, how much?
Wait, why is it so big?
I need a 10.
Let's get rid of all of you then.
Wait, what do you do?
If I play a pair, right.
What happens if I play a pair?
This is just a test to see what happens when I play a pair.
I'll also play these to get rid of them.
What happens if I do a pair?
What do you do?
Shit.
Oh, wait.
No, you do fantastic.
Do that again.
Do it again.
Right now.
Right in front of me.
Oh, that's what I'd like to see.
Okay.
That's what I'd like to see.
I had to make sure.
I wasn't sure.
Okay.
Right.
We made $7.
We need one more dollar, one more doll here, and then we can grab this, which is exactly
what I want.
Oh, wait.
Free Joker.
Sorry.
Sorry, free Joker.
15 multi, one in six chance.
It gets destroyed though.
I mean, it was free.
So I'm not going to be mad.
Sorry.
I am so sorry.
I literally raise all your blood pressures when I do that.
I just forget.
I'm like, oh yeah.
Yeah.
Right.
Oh no.
We're not going to have access to this because I skipped a freaking round.
Did I?
I think so.
Can I sell you?
So there's a chance it gets destroyed.
And I'm like, if there's a chance for it to get destroyed, that's quite high.
I'm tempted to just sell it and then buy this for an extra round at a chance.
Because if it's going to destroy itself, wait, you guys are celebrating the card though.
Oh no.
Once it breaks, you can get another Joker called keep the banana at specials free.
Okay.
I'll keep the banana because I'm not unlocked what the banana does.
Oh, someone says sell though.
Someone says sell hack.
You know what?
Sell hack.
And then give me this.
I want an extra round to increase my odds of success.
One in seven cards gets thrown face down.
That's fine.
I'll survive.
I won't survive.
What the heck are you?
I don't know.
Right.
We'll get rid of the two.
And the seven and the ten I get.
Seven's getting a bit high.
You know what?
I'll just get rid of these playhounds now.
I was four.
Curious.
Whoa.
The molly went off.
Don't mind if I do.
Right.
What are you?
Just to ask.
Okay.
What do you do?
Minus the ante though.
What?
I'm tempted in the ante rewind because we unlocked the hand.
So we would be back to what the usual is but one less in difficulty.
I am tempted.
I'll be honest.
Sly Joker.
Does Sly Joker compliment three of a kind Joker?
Wait.
Three of a kind.
Yeah.
Sombra Apoc.
Thank you for coming to member.
I appreciate it.
I'm sorry to all members who are waiting on the membership ASMR.
I'm a little addicted right now.
Need to get economy going.
Oh, you're right.
But if this is going to reduce the aggro of trying to win, I think we're going to get
some easy rounds in.
If it reduces the aggro, I think it's the best.
It'll give me $9 if I don't play this game.
So I take it because I can't make $9 in a round right now.
Worth it.
Okay.
Initial cards and booster packs in the next shop are free.
Initial cards and booster packs are free.
The booster packs are free.
Yeah.
This one too.
Double skip.
I need to leave now.
Rest well.
Thank you for hanging.
I appreciate it.
Sorry for being addicted.
Worth as well.
Okay.
Discard two random cards pair hand plate.
Oh, no.
You mean I get to...
Oh, wait.
Discard two random cards.
Well, the best I can do is this.
Oh, wait.
In my hand.
Oh, well, we won.
Oh, well.
Thank you, I guess.
Everything is free.
Earn two bucks pair discard if no discards are used.
Thank you.
Destroy two cards.
I don't know if I want to destroy cards yet.
Use two tarot cards.
Choose between a joker.
Let's go.
Each played 10 or four gives 10 chips in a multi.
Every played card permanently...
Oh, we've just started.
So backpack man, you're in.
We've just started.
Use two tarot cards immediately.
We have just started.
Hydration check.
Yes, little reeflings.
Please do hydrate.
I like the lucky cards.
Creates a random joker.
Converts.
Nope.
Okay, it's you.
I think it's you.
And put it on the kings.
I think put it on the kings.
Yeah, two kings locked up on the magician.
I've got one yes.
I'm getting my hand held.
Yeah.
Sure, why not?
Okay.
Good logic then.
Oh, look at that.
Old tassie.
Joker.
Convert up to three.
Nope.
Hot.
What does this do?
Converts a random joker card.
Creates.
Sorry, not converts.
I am not going to go like this one.
This joker gains a multiplier pair consecutive hand played
without playing your most played poker hand.
The obelisk.
Sure.
If we want to destroy...
I mean, it's free, so...
Maybe we'll hold on to it for now
because I don't know if we're going to try and go
for certain numbers or whatever.
That's a hard...
I hope for a good joker.
It's kind of hard.
I mean, it's just going to happen naturally.
Raise the cap on interest earned.
Yes.
This is good for our economy now.
We're only going to be able to get one extra dollar back,
but over time, it's going to add up.
So let's not beat around the bush.
Gives...
Nope.
I don't know what that means.
So we're not playing it.
I don't know what it means.
Ooh!
We've already got double a vase
and I'll throw the four away.
Play hands.
I don't mind if I do.
Delayed gratification.
Six dollars?
Wait, what's delayed gratification?
You earn two bucks per discard
if no discards are used.
That's not delayed gratification.
That's faster than I normally finish.
What are you on about?
Choose one out of four spectra.
A bit of a bank card again.
Is that when I can enhance a card?
Oh, wow.
Delayed gratification.
We'll get you 50 on Mac interest so fast, yeah.
Playing card to add to your deck.
We're kind of a straight flush.
No, I don't even want to waste my money on a straight flush.
Choose...
I think I want a max economy.
Let's do a max economy right away.
One more round and we'll be good to go.
I'm needing some joker cards to shape the way I play the game though.
I think once this gets destroyed we can pick up.
I have a pair joker card.
No, let's do a economy please.
I do 50 chips if played hand contains a pair.
Two pairs, let's go.
Get rid of the nine I guess because I've already got a little cheeky pair right here.
Joker gains for a hand that's not played.
Hanged man on the twos maybe.
Just to get them out of the way.
See, if Fibonacci comes into play...
Full 18!
Delayed gratification is nuts.
Holy crap.
We do have...
This is just straight up for multiplayer.
My banana's gone!
Who took my banana?
Give it back right now.
Give me my banana back.
Great, we're going to get that because that's fantastic.
Right multiplayer, do I need to put it in a certain order?
Maybe after the obelisk?
You don't want to play your best hand every round to scale obelisk.
Ooh.
Okay, maybe we're probably going to swap out obelisk at some point.
Can I get pairs?
Pair love, contains a pair.
Yes, let's level up Mercury.
Nice and simple, we've already got Mercury getting on the thing.
Choose one of three playing cards to add to the deck.
See, I don't have anything that's shaped in a deck right now.
Creates up to two random tarot cards.
I mean, we could get the Wheel of Fortune, you know what?
We could get the Wheel.
Oh.
I will sell you, I don't want to use you.
You destroy up to two selected.
I need some.
Maybe just...
I don't know.
Well, whatever this does, we can buy it because we have 25.
Ooh, I want luck.
Yeah, I want luck, give me lucky.
Lucky, lucky four.
Wait, why did you sell what you just bought?
I'm not going to use it.
I don't like it.
I don't like glass cards.
Um, your interest cap is no 50.
Scam Emperor's Edge, fair enough.
Yeah, I don't like the idea of breaking a card.
Cards played previously, this auntie, or debuff.
That's fain.
That's fain, that doesn't hurt me at all.
Right, I'm just going to play all this to get rid of it.
I think.
Okay, what did that do?
If I get an ace, I have a straight flush.
So just play all of that.
I have so many cards I can play.
I don't like depending on glass though.
Just translate to half a hind man.
I make bad cards, glass.
Yeah, I think I can...
Oh, I do have a straight, you're right.
Oh my god, one, two, three, four.
Just like that.
I forget this straight doesn't have to be an ace.
Like a dumb dumb.
Oh no.
That banana was working overtime.
Not going to lie.
9, 8, 7, 6, 5.
Or 10 maybe.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6.
Is that just going to do it again?
Is that enough?
Oh, this isn't looking so good.
I think I'll be doing ace more quickly than I thought.
Delayed gratification still gave me...
What, six dollars?
But I didn't do it right.
Earn two dollars per discard if no discards are used by the end of the round.
Oh, whatever's remaining at times it by two.
Okay, so three times two is six.
Okay, okay.
Big economy, let's go.
Joker, turret, planet and spectral cards may appear multiple times.
What's that mean?
Foil, holographics are more likely.
But that's just for a chance.
Oh, we've got two celestials though.
Hold on, let's do mega, cheeky mega celestials.
We've got Mercury, straight on Mercury.
Pairs, let's go. Shout out to all my pairs.
Three of a kind contains a pair.
So I am tempted to do three of a kind because it's more likely to occur.
And then we'll do jumbo.
Udinus, two pairs.
Yeah, two pairs.
Let's try that.
Let's even out the kind of pairing match up setup.
Should I do that?
I don't know, I would put my economy below but...
But...
The economy is going very well with delayed gratification.
Going the all render.
Showman is tricky but I wouldn't recommend it unless you have lots of money.
Remember that max economy is 50.
Oh, it stays 50?
So I'm burning through my max economy.
Delayed gratifications giving us like 50 bucks around.
I know I shouldn't be greedy but can create two common jokers.
I don't even have room.
You can be a little greedy.
We've got a triple and nothing else actually.
Just use these up.
Let's see if we can get our double four.
Don't forget to hydrate.
98765.
Just like that.
All done.
Good luck on the straight.
Cash out to 15.
Getting this game was a mistake.
I'm fucking addicted.
Celestial pack jumbo.
Oh, I love streamer luck.
It's real and unfathomable with a base.
What joker was that?
Sorry, I keep burning through.
One discard each round.
Wait, are you...
You thing you play into this one?
I'm wondering if I should get rid of the obelisk.
I technically am going to make $2 extra every time this guy is hanging out with the obelisk.
You still have a slot?
What did you call me?
What did you call me, Riffin?
Tarot card. Choose one tarot card.
No, let's...
Hold on to some economy.
It gives us a spectral function.
I...
Exactly, that's what I thought.
$2 double Vs.
Five chips every time.
It's plead. And the same round.
Forever.
Oh yeah, yeah, upgrade.
Oh wow, okay, holy crap.
I'm starting to...
Get it. Mildly.
I'm starting to get it.
I want to upgrade all my...
Everything then, I guess.
Oh wait, the four didn't count.
Sorry, I'm not paying attention.
I'm just having fun putting it together.
I think they've got me. I'm sorry.
I think I've been hook, lain, and sinkered.
Hook, lain, and sink...
What? Hook, lain, and sinker!
There.
Okay, there we go.
I'm not like paying attention because we don't have to sweat just yet.
But when we have to start sweating,
don't think I won't be looking at you as reference
for advice, because I don't know what I'm doing.
Delayed gratification gave us...
Fuah. See? We've already made it back.
Played cards with clubs gives a molly.
One molly per tarot card used.
This run?
Wait!
I'ma start flying left and right with tarot cards.
If that... If I comprehend this correctly...
If I comprehend this correctly,
throw that out
and then put that in
and then go nuts buying stuff.
Sell your red joker?
This guy?
I think sell the obelisk
because I'm only going to want to do pairs.
Yeah, I want to sell the obelisk.
It works. I'm using it right now.
Are you playing? Are you playing?
At the same time as me?
You're supposed to give me advice!
You're supposed to tell me how to win.
You've got to play it on your own.
Right, sell the obelisk because the obelisk
is going to start getting a bit useless.
Tarot card buy.
So you'll multiply.
I'm going to start dropping tarot cards
left and right. That's all I'm saying.
Celestial pack? Let's go.
Oh!
Mercury.
Oh, we love to see it mercury.
We do. And then use two
two Tarots. Right, let's go.
The Wheel of Fortune.
Oh, wait. Hold on. Hold on.
Don't get... Hold on. Hold on. Pause. Pause. Pause.
Don't get too ahead of yourself.
I still need to read because I don't know what to do.
Left card comes to right.
Create two planetary cards.
Curious. Create the last Tarot card.
Oop!
Create the last Tarot card or Planet card
used during this run.
The full is excluded. Mercury.
I can level up pairs again with a full.
Use the full.
We're using the full.
We're going to use that now.
We're also going to delete some cards.
No, we're not. We have to use it in-game apparently.
Rude. And then it's my little guy.
Oh my god, he's up at four!
Right. And then imagine
he gets hit with the Wheel of Fortune though.
It's hard to use the Wheel.
You can use the Hanged Mana.
I just need to select.
Oh, my apologies. Okay.
Let's just get rid of the lower ones then.
Okay. Do we get rid of the lower ones?
Right. Hydration. Sorry.
My tea's getting cold again.
I cannae stream and drink tea at the same time.
All the cheese, honestly.
My Apocrates.
Yeah, I don't have anything that is telling me
unless the Fibonacci comes up
instantly after this.
Then four and six.
I mean, we could bet the Fibonacci shows up.
If we do four and six then...
Yeah.
Fuck it. We're going to see.
He's up at five now.
Multi-Cards.
Planet.
Possibly.
Planet Earth.
Risk it.
I ain't risk it.
No!
But it went up though.
It went up though. That's all I care about.
Money go up. First hand is drawn face down.
Thanks, I guess.
We have five turns. Four discards.
Hear me out.
Just go for it.
Yeah.
Yeah. Okay.
We got a double ten!
We got four thousand for that little cheeky move there.
We'll do the eights and then we'll
unflip all of these guys as well.
I know it's not going to be a thing
but we'll unflip them.
Beautiful. Stunning.
Gorgeous.
You just love this game.
It goes there. Identify yourself.
We're actually going to have to do a discard
because there's nothing we can do.
That's actually really rare.
Normally we can always do something every round.
One, two, three, four, five.
I know I should keep that but we're literally a thousand off
so just do a discard.
If I play it, I get to keep a dollar.
I get to keep two dollars
if I don't use the discard
so I'm just going to play nothing.
Lucky can give you cash.
So we're just going to play nothing
and do a high card or whatever you call it.
Alright, there we go.
We got troops.
Well, then that's it.
Okay.
Yay!
I'll try to finish my tea.
There we go. 18 for that one round.
Fantastic.
Reroll boss blind one time per anti.
10 bucks though
to do that.
If we get a really...
Choose one of four joker cards.
No!
Of course when I pick up tarot cards
it doesn't give me tarot cards.
Use run info to check the boss blind.
Run info?
Blinds. Wait, can I see what's up ahead?
Play only one type.
This is upcoming.
What's vouchers?
Oh, this is what I have.
Vouchers redeem this run.
Okay.
I completely forgot I got all these.
I'm not very smart, I mean.
No, only one hand, yeah.
Only one type.
Play only one hand type this round.
How does that work?
How the heck is that supposed to work?
All flushes?
One...
One kind of hand.
Only for peers.
Well, better be peers.
Choose two of up to five playing cards
to add to the deck.
I'm not even wanting that, if I'm being honest.
I'm wanting tarot.
Do I want this in my back pocket?
Decisions, decisions.
Yeah, have it in my back pocket?
Okay.
I don't know how to utilize it,
but I'm not wanting anything else for this.
Gives a spectral pattern.
No, I need tarot cards.
The game's pleasing me dry a little bit here.
You're not really giving me much to work with.
Literally a double, and that's it.
Just play that and get rid of it all.
Like, the game has not been nice to me.
Unless I'm missing something obvious,
that was not a nice pull.
Heart flush?
Shit.
For...
King, Queen Jack 10.
So I need an Ace or a Nine.
I'm so sorry.
I don't see things the way you see it.
I could do...
I could do Jacks, I can't.
King like that.
And get rid of the...
Oh, but four is like a good bonus.
Like, ever do these, maybe?
Aren't her pairs worth more than flushes anyway?
Very plausible.
My pair is level six right now, so...
RNG gods?
Thank you.
Oh yeah, my pairs are worth way more.
Shout out to all my pairs.
Cash out.
Ooh, what are you?
Allow straights to be played with gaps in them.
Well, I'm actually doubled out.
You're too late to show up.
I'm already down on doubles.
Give 20 more chips and a multiplier.
Well, we're going to get our tarot card multiplier up.
So...
It's a hollow joker though.
Is that what I'm looking at?
Actually sell the four plus joker and buy the straight cards.
And buy this one?
Not the scholar, buy the...
straight cards.
The straight card is 10 multiplier.
Okay, I trust you, Reeflings.
You're gating me.
Okay, that's a 10 multiplier.
Okay, and then we'll do our tarot cards
because we can get...
this will go up.
Enhance to two lucky cards.
Enhance us to the bonus cards
or create a random joker.
I think...
we'll do lucky cards.
Yeah, let's make these two lucky.
Let's make these two lucky.
It could be good, but you probably have to sell the drunk jack.
This game is actually insane
with how deep it goes.
It's fantastic.
It's honestly fantastic.
I'm loving it.
So I can get 19 bucks back.
I can get a planet.
I can do the lucky card again.
I'm tempted to do the lucky card.
I really enjoy the luck.
I really enjoy the luck factor
because
a 20 multiplier is insane.
Priestess gives you two planets though.
I love the luck factor,
but you're right.
Two planets, I could upgrade everything.
Well, not everything.
I could upgrade
and play.
Priestess might actually be better in this situation.
Okay, okay.
What we got? We've got four of a kind
and a full house. I mean, we're just going to utilize them.
I don't have a problem with utilizing them.
Right, and then we'll go next.
I am not interested in you.
Every played card permanently gains five chips.
I'm already on that.
So what are you? Allow straights to be played
in a gap.
Wait.
That example works?
Wait, it's not like five, four, three,
one and...
Wait, I'm just going to be doing straights
all day long then.
Am I misunderstanding?
We rose in the next shop for zero.
And a 10 plus multiplier on top.
Oh, is it the 10 multi?
That is what we're wanting it for.
So you can play very weird straights now.
My brain can hardly
like, comprehend. So what?
One, two,
skip a few.
Ten, skip eight.
No way!
That's redonkulous.
That doesn't make sense,
but it does!
It just works!
All right, Todd Howard.
You can't down there, good sir.
Hurry up with my Skyrim six already.
I'm winning.
Whoa, that's mean-blowing!
Eleven, ten.
Eight.
Well, that's ten, technically.
Nine and eight. Wow!
How bizarre!
I'm like twiddling
my hair right now
in between my fingers.
Like, what?
How strange.
So king, queen,
jack, ten, nine,
seven.
And what? And then we need a five
or six?
What?
All right, okay, okay, hold on.
What have we got? We've got doubles.
Let's do doubles.
That's blowing my mind.
Wait, have I got straight again?
No. Wait, no.
Have I?
King, queen, jack, ten, nine,
eight, seven. No!
Wait, that's so hard!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
That's like so weird!
How common is that card?
Okay, so there's
three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
It worked!
Why does it work?
Wait, this card is so OP.
Danny, you put my stonks in the streets?
I think Danny, you put my stonks in the streets.
King, queen, jack,
ten, nine.
Okay, I don't have that.
Five, six, seven, eight, nine,
ten. Okay, so I don't have it that way.
Go in all in on streets.
I think so.
I think we need to maybe swap off
repair. Oh no, but that's got a ten plus on it.
Does that activate in general?
Okay, I'm going to get rid of all the...
Oh wait, no, I don't want to get rid of them.
I don't think so. I just want to get rid of the kings.
Because we're like so close to another street.
Oh, it's the end of the round.
Oh.
How bizarre, right?
Let me finish this game.
It's cold!
I can't help it.
Remaining hand, money, interest.
Oh, I got rid of my...
No.
Why did that not...
Why did you not activate?
Earn two bucks
per discard if no discards are used.
Oh, if none of them are used.
Okay, at all.
Right, what's going on here?
I've already had you, so
I don't want you.
There is another to make it that you only need floor cards
to make flushes and streets.
The Joker has literally changed the entire game.
We have...we've got a turret card
so we can increase our multiplier at
8 to 9.
Yes, please, sir.
What have we got? Planets.
Joker, we don't need.
Double's money.
That gives us 20.
That would give us full economy.
Wait, that gives us two more turret cards?
Which gives us even more of a multiplier.
Emperor.
Emperor?
Yeah, okay.
That turns us to what?
10?
Wait, that turns us to 11?
Enhance something into a wealth card.
Use the wheel.
I never got it.
But is that 10 now? Enhances one selected card
into a wild card.
I don't know what a wild card is.
But in Binding of Isaac,
we've got a wild card.
You hear an audio cue and the guy goes wild card.
I just thought you should know that.
Right, we will pick a planet to upgrade as well
because
I guess we want straight.
Not straight flush.
That's very unlikely
but a straight wild card.
Sorry, I'm stuck in my head now.
Saturn.
Cumberboard Saturn.
Right, you...
You don't have a multiplier with your foil.
You have 50 chips
which I'm not really sure.
Saturn.
Sell the drunk Joker.
The drunk Joker.
I have
the drunk card.
Sell the drunk card.
I would pick the foil Joker
and switch it for the discard.
Okay, thank you.
You and you come.
God ranks give chips when...
Okay, okay.
I comprehend interesting.
I like it. I'll use the lover's card
and then our multiplier will go to what?
Ten.
Fantastic.
Fan.
Chips.
That's kind of scary.
Play only one hand this round.
I'm a bit nervous.
Alright.
Enhance one into a wild card.
One hand type.
So...
Go with either pairs or straights.
Play only straight.
I don't have a straight.
No ASMR.
No, it's coming. Once we redirect into Azure
I'm doing my ASMR.
You might hear the birds outside though.
That's only...
That's only done so I didn't ASMR a bit later.
Hand type.
You can just play straights.
Ten, nine, eight, seven,
six, five, four.
Right, so I need to get rid of
all of these.
Even the four?
Wild card.
Sorry, that's really stuck in my head.
I'll discard these
and we'll go for a flush.
Discard some sevens.
Ten, nine, eight, sevens.
Help.
Jeez, I'm a waste. Do you guys not want me
to win or something? What's going on here?
King is very far away from ten.
Wait, I got a straight. Stop. Stop.
Where?
I don't have a straight.
King.
Queen. Jack.
Ace, king, ten.
Wait, queen and joker.
Queen and jack get skipped
between these two?
No, you said a flush.
Wait, never mind. Yeah.
Toss one of the nine and keep a ten.
She wants straights,
not flushes. No, you can't make a straight.
I didn't think so.
So ditch this nine and these two.
Discard nine of hearts, discard four.
But not three? Why not three?
Why not three?
Wait a minute, why did you not mention the three?
I don't know.
I'm going to need to make a play.
My discards are getting off.
Okay, here we go. Here we go.
Yeah, okay, right.
Lovers, what's a wild card though?
That I put ten on?
That I just randomly put the ace on a wild card?
Sure, what does it do? I don't know.
Can be used as any suit.
Sure.
Play.
Nine, eight, seven.
Shit.
We've, oh no, we've fucked it.
We've fucked it.
We've ballsed it up.
I've ballsed it up because I used so many discards.
Used the last discard.
Reroll a three and a two.
Man, you're actually getting awful draws.
Streamer Luck can only lead stretch so far.
Discard all the threes and twos.
And the four?
Or not the four?
Jobu Nogo.
Thank you for the membership.
I appreciate it.
You have a good basis though.
For a lot of straights.
So get rid of this side. Leave the four.
I'd keep the four, not the four.
Just the threes and the twos.
Last discard.
It's either make or break.
Um...
Nine, eight, seven, six, five, four!
Ok, ok let them get up, let them get up, let them get up!
Hold on.
Oh, thank goodness, that was not fun.
I didn't enjoy that.
Don't do that to me again.
absolutely we'll muck around with tarot cards no problem wait what's this one
consumable slot so I can have even more tarot cards mega arcane use two
tarots right we're gonna buy and use the planets right now got a bit of
Uranus please use and a bit of Venus please use for three of a kind
unfortunately didn't roll Saturn which is what we were wanting but that's fine
tarot open up please come to me right ladies and gentlemen we can double money
for a max of 20 which we can achieve create a card destroy two cards increase
the rank and mid game or enhance one selected card into a stone card when
can you use vouchers mid game I mean no vouchers always occur oh actually yeah I
don't know when the director's cut could be activated 20 is 20 you're you are
factually correct I am inclined to agree actually don't want to destroy
anything because if we've now got this weird suit thing going on destroying is
bad we don't want Joker that's useless we don't really need to change anything
into the same thing because we're going for a weird flush so yeah hermit is our
only option there we go 20 bucks right not you not you again don't want to
destroy cards or create a Joker wow okay this is useless is this a skip all
but but our multiplier you know what I can take it I don't want to actually use
it I thought it was gonna let me take it and then I could just sell it yeah I
thought I could take it I destroy high and low no the problem is we have what's
called shortcut it allows straights to be inaccurate you could bump the three and
fours to four and five centering the value you know what you like beyond a
certain what do you want me to do you can bump the three and fours wait so
should I make the three or four and then that would raise the bar
increase the strip the rank increases rank of the two cards selected by one
card okay okay that was good we are now 14 multiply which is fantastic we don't
need a Joker we don't need a consumable slot we're actually about to hit max
economy which is fantastic for us because our little discards this one
really isn't hitting it isn't hitting as hard anymore so I might want to
replace but gives us a negative Joker slot on the domestic is an extra slot so
I can't get rid of it right next round delayed gratifications and I am
learning and make a standard pack no I want that rocked cards right we can
still do our little Duble V at the moment was at nine wait hold on five six
seven eight nine ten oh wait that's a flush I think I'm better doing my pairs
yeah pairs are better right now so just throw them away and go for a little
flush I don't know maybe it's terrible sorry for folk that sorry for folk that
but I'm trying well I got 13k for that yeah seven six five four three two one
of course I'm not gonna card that would be too easy let's just do doubles I think
we've got all we can do a full house and yeah because a single pair is heavily
boosted single pair please better than two pairs wait
single pair who says single pair please better who says run info how do you do
the mass straight flush two pair is 60 times four
oh wow wait it was 85 times seven that's a big number
wait oh no don't maybe the math oh no you're right a single pair is far
stronger wow okay and what are you odd numbers so a double seven is stronger
than a Wow this game wait wait wait let me I know give me I need to some
freaking math in my head I'm like that's a bigger number you're right 11,000
for two singular pair wow we need that half cut off card again and we're laughing
to the bank hmm right we've got 69 bucks play played face card gives 30 right
I'm gonna buy this because our economy is good and we've got two tarot cards
let's do you thank you redeemed thank you right jumbo what see what we're
dealing with give us a suit right no to the glass card and the last thing we
used was strength which I've already forgotten what does it in this game I
think strength increases your health by one in Isaac as well as a speed and
possibly damage 69 nice big bank of our it says there oh increases rank of
two selected cards ah so we are officially created a five and four so
can we just do it again anyway two selected car no enhance one into a
wild card sorry convert no right actually yeah the fool is the best thing
we can probably do right here so we made an artificial five that isn't really a
five but we can bump up to a six so there should be a double five okay hearts
have a double five which is fine so you have more fives than normal and less
threes so I don't want to read you don't have to worry too much if you use the
fuel it will go back to the shop yeah and spades doesn't have a three I'm not
smart enough to do it
huh my dumb very dumb very dumb it's okay I'm allowed to be dumb make two lucky
cards hearts or a steel card chariot oh this is hard because I'm trying to do
what a straight so having a chariot on standby I don't know if I'm better because
I'm going to be going through so many cards it might be better to have two
lucky cards steal the three really and then hope the other cards are straight
when I get them
not do this now oh I can do that now hold on right what my two strengths use
strength here first yes sorry I noticed I was gonna do that and what is steel
steel is a 1.5 multiplier if it just sits in your hand like you don't utilize it
it gives a big thing use strength on three and four I guess since they're low
numbers we want to bump everything upwards of five so we can always push
towards and you can save strength using as an emergency the multiplier though
we're at 15 multiplier just on fortune teller so I'm just gonna go balls to the
wall with it we're now at 16 multiplier right and then we'll lose oh someone
wants me to steal you can save now well I've already used it now strength on five
and four what about multi steal the four okay I'm doing it I'm doing as a
reflander man we're now 17 multiply which is fantastic four of a kind I'm not
even going for you let's go next please nah I don't need free jokers I've got
quite an interesting joker right King Queen Jack 1098 well there you go
straight already yes yes 13,000 for that what we already got a little baby
straight over here oh no we don't close to no cigar and these Kings are gonna
give insanely good stuff but the I'm so close to getting something here I'm
wondering if I should just throw that away and go for like a low straight I do
have a pair of Kings oh wait yeah that's right I have a pair shut up tell my
pairs I still have a pair boom because I'd leveled up pairs so much going all
in with them right King Queen Jack 10 I don't have a baby pair I have three
rounds so I'm not very stressed out about it I'm just gonna play this pair here
and kind of clear out the inventory and try and go high for a bit because I did
put my money into high like making other cards at a higher value so yes not
problem not problem we're getting there delayed gratification 21 bucks don't
mind if I do oh this joker gains two Maltese of hand played contains two
pair brah we're trying to swap straight I need tarot cars give me tarot yes I
can buy diamonds the chariot oh wait enhance one slighted card into a steel
card I wouldn't mind doing that again honestly creates up to two random well
that's even more the Emperor's just infinite glitch seven yeah what's it
okay glass car and don't actually want to use it on a wild car oh wait oh no I'm
inventory I actually don't want to make a glass card enhance one selected card
into a gold card if I buy this oh oh wait I can hold three oh my gosh I'm so
smart choose up to one of three playing cards add to the deck let's give it a
peach create a planet card for final played poker hand around if held in hand
must have room I mean a 10 is high and either way it's like good if we get any
more cards that are in the higher end of things that's just a free Saturn got it
say less say less are we considering this Joker I don't think so it says two
pairs but we're doing straights from around here so no thank you we're going
to go ham using all of these and then we are going to get a 20 multiplier from
fortune teller alone the pants might be better than your right most Joker this
good this gives chips but not multiplayer I mean you might be right this
just gives chips but the multiplayer is so much better I wouldn't I wouldn't give
odd Todd I if anything I'd actually sell hiker isn't hiker not adding so much to
the game because I got him at the start that gives one point five on the multi
to hikers add in a lot of chips in the background hikers still very valuable I
think because I had him at the start is valuable if he showed up late game
completely agree with you like no and that's the 10 multiplayer not getting
rid of that definitely not getting rid of that so really it is as odd Todd is
goner and but hiker doesn't add much now slide joker is probably the worst
what I've got right now but he's a 10 holographic 10 multiplier but you could
survive without him right now hiker added the value already doesn't go away
right even after you sell it 1.5 versus 10 chips okay I think you're right it's
either hiker or odd Todd too this is a situation where any of the choices might
be good because I am doing so much straight stuff like with straights it
might be better to keep odd Todd and get rid of the hiker since he's just he's
very he's doing increasing very slowly so I am gonna make a mistake and pick
hiker but that's my gut is telling me hiker doesn't make sense at this point
in time the Joker games to a multiplier of played hands contain two pairs so
we're gonna do a few pairs on purpose on poor pause and we will also utilize all
these cards and so we oh it's the last run base chips and multis are halved the
flint okay I want to keep you nine eight seven good thing you have a lot of
bonuses yes all right what's going on we're here well okay I am just gonna use
these like no but is it lovers because what do you do can be used as a any suit
it enhance the card into a golden one I'm just using it on random there's not
really a logic to it and you're you 20 now and a glass card I really don't like
the idea surely the first glass card I ever use will not actually destroy the
card well we added an artificial 10 so really we should destroy a 10 right I'll
do five twos and then if an attend shows up with added an artificial one that
doesn't oh let's see what we look for round one right King Queen Jack skip eight
nine that's a straight I'm gonna destroy the three right now so it doesn't matter
if it gets destroyed oh wow actually stayed oh I didn't understand what that
was gonna do like the nine chips three bucks if you get to keep it in your hand
though I wanted to keep this in my hand creates the planet card for the final
plate poker hand all around if held in hand play if held in hand
two pairs play and then we can upgrade sat and it was a net Saturn Saturn oh it's
Uranus shoot oh that's two pair multiplier though that's not bad at all yeah sure thank
you right what's this all card impacts are cheaper yes please let's redeem that
now so we can fire sale oh that's a good one hand size goes up by one if poker
hand is a straight flush no that's too rare even I've never done that but we're
tarot carded out the wazoo what we got increase ranked destroy convert I guess
increase rank and keep everything increase rank oh wait sorry I'll try and
push everything up on the other side of the board and then we can use two tarot
cards which again is gonna make this guy go out the wazoo Joker stone parts
planet our 16 bucks back I want to say planet yeah planet come on give me what
I need four of a kind sure and then airs full house sure right well got 16 bucks
Joker don't need stone don't want don't want right fit 16 boxes 16 bucks what we
are 24 multiplier it's going up we're not gonna oh we can't re-roll we're above
50 one re-roll I don't want to use it though
we're just gonna upgrade everything right one more one more re-roll
goodness goodness to pair yes okay next round we're at 50 we're at the top next
no we're cuz the economy is good we don't need it you know we don't need it I'd buy
the stars just above fortune teller I think I have to use it but I don't want
to oh wait does it make a difference if I shuffle decks it doesn't make a
difference I don't go for straight flushes all right we're gonna keep that
juicy tens sitting high and dry wait if I do I think I actually need to
purposely do two pairs two pair yes and then odd is gonna activate on the five
is Jack considered an odd I guess so I love straight that fine now to do right
if it okay so this gun yeah okay okay I'm happy with the two pairs let's go
lovely jubb leaving we love to see it right you get to stay in my hand so does
the 10 everything else honestly can be shoved out the window question mark
nothing else is complimenting so I could probably go for she's gorilla in nearly
one shot that yeah I can't believe them right so I'm gonna leave you on purpose
everything else I'm just gonna go for some sort of high double cuz my cards are
higher right you and wait maybe a single pair will do it shout out to all my
pairs a single pair might do it a single pair did it absolutely use mercury
holy crap that's two cars we got we got 16 bucks for that feels good man a
straight absolutely yes please celestial planet and turret but we're
gonna get both so it's not problem Saturn again oh feels freakin good man I
think we may actually win this choose one of the turret cards yet strength 16
bucks something into a gold card if you hold it you get money I don't really
need money like that and a glass part no I think just money again and real increase
the rank of a car
do I do it that increase these not money money money money money money money
strength strength on the twos okay strength on the twos let's do that we
still get a multiplayer up for doing it so we're gonna re-roll no we're not
we're too poor we're in 59 okay let's play it safe we're not gonna don't need
to re-roll anything else how are you doing you're six multiplier right now
so we're gonna try and get a few more twos and that's so cool on the eyes I
don't know how well it translates on stream but that's so cool on the eyes
that's exactly how it looks when you get like a card like that and really no I
don't need to skip 52 lose a dollar per card that's fine I do not mind the tooth
give me the tooth every round I'll take it right we could do two doubles again
and get this guy leveled up again further and I think that's probably the
wisest delayed gratification I don't know how much we're actually needing you
hang about now I'm gonna do two dubs I know I should probably can go for
straights because we're putting all our money into it but it looks pretty good
to me oh the card didn't break
um thank you I'll take it so now currently on 8 multi oh my god this is
so satisfying so satisfying like oh yeah it's all coming together you only care
about delayed gratification because it's a negative okay so it's not going
anywhere but and we just have one pair hanging out you know that we have four
rounds it's not really a big deal if we do like a lore thing like this on it the
singular pair the singular pair one is whoa oh my god and we got fricking to
yes use it now oh my god what are you enhance the steel card yes justice
enhance one selected and I got sure knock yourself out one planet card to use
come on give a Saturn baby oh close enough high card full house for the kind
I never get for a full house is three and two and and the two will compliment
pair I think airs earth is the best choice yes I agree with you sorry after I
did the effect after I did the math in my head I agree with you that that is the
best choice full house contains a pair isn't two and two better at this point
and I let's see let's see what it actually claims I wish I would do the
number math for me instead of giving me percentage like times I understand it
can't do it but a singular pair is 800 two pairs of 600 okay I need to remember
a singular pair truly is stronger but a straight is insanely strong four of a
kind honestly isn't lagging behind too much nor is the full house so who's
stronger a straight and then a pair not two pairs stop playing two pairs and we
don't need a new Joker Joker card and we're gonna use these right
eeps okay I lose a buck every time a player brown that's fine it doesn't
convert three cards into diamonds that doesn't make a difference because we're
not we're not doing suits or anything like that so it doesn't matter two pairs
add a permanent multiplier ah yes I forgot about that part go for straight
flush yeah two pairs just make a bunch of diamonds like a diamond in the sky right
so never on 27 enhances something into a steel card sure let's just make you a
steel car may steal the three sorry sorry alright steel three just say and
then a chance to destroy a car sure I'm just gonna use that wine now we are now
49 multi-pliers just getting juicy I'm here for it right just do a singular
pair a singular pair is stronger than a double kind of not quite nine eight
seven six five four three up nine eight seven six five four three oh no I want to
keep it though Jack I got a 60,000 in that I got a 60,000 I got a 60 fricking
thousand feels good man I kind of want to finish with the three mama I'm hungry
where are you I'm going to start teaching other reflames are you sitting in the
ASMR chat are you guys sitting waiting for me in the ASMR chat in the member
stream oh my god you are I'm so sorry oh no the roof ones are sitting in the
number stream waiting for me I'm so sorry thank you sleaze labor for the tip
oh no they're waiting for me to use one too busy fucking sitting gambling ten nine
eight seven six five win insta win and an extra tip on top I'm sorry we flinch
it is I'm the promise that is the ones gonna happen we redirecting into a zero
whenever she comes online which I actually don't know when twenty four
dollar reduce don't mind if I do right so let's tail pack get in my belly yes
please yes please yes we are getting so freaking lucky playing cards can be
purchased from the shop I want that I don't know if I want that I don't think
I want that playing choose one of up to four cards to add to the day sure can I
get like a purple whoa what are you ten mole player on a king what ten mole
player wow reroll okay I'm addicted and I don't want to stop I'm a bit all the
right now I think this is the run we flinch wait no no I'm better off
waiting for this because I can add to this over town and I'm doing straights
anyway don't don't tempt me devil Joker card don't tempt me wild card one and
four chance to create a tarot card oh well that would actually be so good for
my run right now okay one more we roll oh so good everything is everything's
coming up me it's so good everything sorry that's not the saying it's like
oh everything's coming up sunny or something like that I'm sorry I've
forgotten what the actual I don't know the actual phrases net go next yeah if I
do a I've only got four bucks to spend okay next and then the lovers can be
turned into a wild card whoa two pairs might be better now let's see two pairs
120 times seven what number is that internet battle fail thank you for
becoming a member I promise I'm doing the member ASMR very shortly I'm just
addicted okay I think it's all coming together do you have all the unlocks I
this is the first time I've played this game I am in love I love you guys holding
my hands through it you guys have you have you have eagle eyes all I'm saying
about me so you're the eagle on my back because you have eagle eyes and level
seven for the straight yep right let me do some math 100 times 8 is 800 100 times
7 700 and then add 5 which makes it 840 so two pairs are now stronger close
enough close enough I know that the two pairs are stronger it's close enough
okay I don't know how to do math I'm just happy to be here I'm at the big
number good she knows her math sometimes I have to do it in like segments I have
to always do stuff times by five and then or times by ten and like trying to
the other way around two pairs orders we don't even have to tell you anything
you're already kicking nine seven six five oh I didn't even see that nine seven
six five four level seven oh what are you gonna do baby show me show me what
you're made of
we're gonna win we're gonna win right what I need last no go away gold not
really steal steal give us a steal on a five steal for sure yeah put on a five
put on a nice little nice little five well I say hello four of a kind of a
flush I'm just gonna buy these because I can I've got the money I've got the
disposable income please use your disposable income don't need a joker card
I didn't eat a reroll I said I need a reroll when small blind or big blind is
like to gain one more give me it okay I am satisfied steal that ten we rule
your jokers are perfect I don't want to skip the shop shit the odds of us getting
straights are very high if we increase our hand size by three but if we increase
if we skip the shop we might miss out on something big don't skip boss reroll what
what what have can I tell what it's gonna reroll into it just is very large blind
I assume there's no reroll in the final boss it's random it might make it worse
like if it turns around and says you can't play whatever no we're making sorry
we're making like 60,000 per hand I think I'm better playing and trying to get
another multiplier I think play to beat three you need to hit straights like
crazy reroll I am all then you have like six rerolls on the boss
my brain is telling me play this go to the shop I can upgrade I can play these two and upgrade
this by like 32 as well max procs thank you for coming a member during such a stressful time
we're gonna do it I think I'd risk the boss reroll as it stands you have to hit
straights every single and that's rough go with your boss normal number is much lower than
that runes or streaks fuck
cerulean bell means it's it's fine I won wait so does skip to have three more in my hand
and then I can play these like as I get in because it'll add to the multiplier yeah you can do it or
fuck oh fuck I'll show this right what's going on a wild card or do you do 10 queen okay I can't go
that way queen has to be played so what wild card a king and just do a double single king
oh wait no hold on two pair is stronger than a pair a flush is way stronger though
you can also just discard it or discard it has to be played or discarded wait hold on let the
reeflings think right let me just add a load of shit because this is going to add to our multiplier
enhance two selected cards to multi cards whoa that's actually really big 10% messing around
I can do well this turn it to a pair is not going to turn it to a pair
king king queen six six do you want king let me activate the lover's card on this
wait why do you know what enhance one selected card into a wild card why did that not work
wait oh wait it was going to do it to the queen
oh I mean it's going to put my multiplier up anyway
yeah so that didn't really do anything that's fine
your queen is forced to be selected empress will affect it okay we don't want that then so king king
nine nine because I've got an odd number king king nine nine double will activate spear trousers
odd will activate on the nine um nodders yeah yeah okay we've got agreements let's see what number
are we gonna pull are we gonna win oh my god we might win
six five wait six seven eight nine five
and I can shove some mullies on it too while I'm at it why not why not why not I think we've won
I think we've won nine eight seven six five I think we've done it we won virtual we actually did it
you dealt that with that pretty well oh my god we did it it took us so long but we
got there in the end told you you can do a hundred k in two hands wow
okay when does the zero come on do I have time for another or do I need to get off
oh my god wait endless mode we can keep going
oh endless mode
no stroney is there is live in twin okay well just keep mucking about uh
well just keep mucking about we're not gonna like actually do anything like it's just gonna
get harder one card slot available in the shop yeah it looks good to me that run took two hours
most people quit before they get rich but you didn't quit no I didn't let's see the planet
a double pair looks good to me urinus a bit of an urinus right so we've finished the game
um we'll buy this because it'll upload it'll update our little guy everyone everyone's being
so complimentary after defeating the boss blind you gain money I don't need that oh I'm going to
keep the 10 on my persons right select three cards to turn into the moon and then our little
thing will get upgraded uh whoa what a rubbish hand ace king queen jack knight and then I get to
keep the 10 which will give me a thingy mob over
ace king queen jack oh I guess I could not do that but I feel like it's so much faster
Zal thank you for the five gifted membership is that because I won be honest is that because I won
thank you that's a surprise congrats to those who caught it with their face
they'll leave the queen I don't know the queens although the queen might be a oh no I'm not gonna
utilize yeah fuck it fuck it send it how much did I get for doing this
oh my god we got 64 for that oh and we have the double pair to upgrade our little pair of my pair
of pants over here yeah we have like so much fucking time and room I don't know oh wow we
actually didn't make it there we do have a 10 singular 10 to play I'm happy with a singular 10
we get to our little spades card and we got mercury for pear use not bad not bad use it's
cuz the model's really cute oh yeah yeah like my mecha hey yeah 21 books I just got that for like
21 books right tarot card that's what I love to see cuz it's gonna upgrade us what are we thinking
no diamonds another steel
the hanged man the hierophant
ah steel a jack maybe
strone is cute nothing oh jeffy I'm not leaking anymore at scotch and I'm straight up waving
are you squinting me right now oh oops I was having such a good time I forgot to give you a very small
victory no you didn't have to do that it's great seeing you have so much oh thank you so much I'm
glad you guys are having fun too I'm addicted that's so good steel jack is good okay I will
steal jack and the chariot all done where are we at 34 a straight flush is so rare I don't
think it's happening with me increase hand size there's nothing we need from here choose one
oh wait a playing card wait was it gonna is it special playing cards
oh and you come and you come and you come right okay I'm actually kind of glad right we've got one
reroll in us straight flush is more common now for you I think oh is it okay it's only two
dollars as well right we're gonna do a reroll oh come on come on give it no right okay we're at 35
though wheel of fortune let's go no what we use it three times technically right one more reroll
what we got net chin one and two card to create a tarot when a booster pack is open
I've tried it three times create a tarot card if the poker hand contains an ace or a straight
brah we'd be tarotting out the wazoo but I don't know what I would give up for that
things about I mean hold on
hold on odd Todd in exchange for create a tarot card which is going to constantly bounce off
of fortune tellers cheeks huh it's something to consider
it's too late for polarity you think it's too late it's too late and an abstract one okay okay
I do not have enough for another reroll I want to maximize that income okay it's too late I will
okay thank you thank you thank you I am I am learning give us one dollar played hand I get 54
bucks for skipping this wait that's worth it then but it skips the shop but it's 54 bucks
playing a two pair sets money to zero
all face cards are drawn face down
yeah we definitely didn't oh no
is that a mistake possibly
54 bucks to skip but I need to buy stuff
polarity is cool when you delete your middle cards and just get tarts over hand
I think I'd do it for 54 bucks but we don't get access to the shop so if we mess up like this is it
strongy you're endless every round we'll get higher and higher until you break
until I break we're here to break the game if I get if I can mess around with 54 bucks so that's so big
enough fuck it
fuck it 103 have we even had 103 on our persons before
right face down face cards are drawn down
hmm
10 9 10 9 8 7 6 5
this will be a flush guaranteed but we will
subs we will forfeit a tarot card if I do it
not bad not bad oh this is getting a bit tricky though
so these are all high so really I'm just going for a double up here high
I don't really have a choice in the matter
I don't really want to I want to keep you yeah this is the best I can do considering discard
the face cards maybe dig for straights maybe just delete them it's just because we know they're high
so there's the odds are there's likely a singular pair in here
hmm but you're right though I could maybe get a straight low straight
how many how many rounds I've already done one fourth of it but I have four hands left if I
fuck this up it's just the likelihood of these being high or a pair is pretty decent
and oh shit wait maybe not no wait you guys are right holy shit you're right
10 9 8 7 6 5
yeah and then there'll be a multiplier because of what's on my hand
no that was the correct choice thank you guys thank you for letting me think a little bit there
uh ace
if there's not a queen in here we can't do a straight from here
we might be able to do a straight
or do we just play a singular ace what happens if it's a king
we don't make it what happens if it's a queen then we make it
it's a jack a queen or a king
you still have three hands
fuck it I'm here for the gamble we already won we already won so we can gamble like crazy
we already won so we can do these silly silly actions that no one should do at home
uh well a double four clear it I think it will yeah a double four will clear it no problem
oh I fish my smart smart smart fish smart fish
16 bucks the money's getting lesser
oh don't mind if I do
uh urinus also levels up what's this permanently add a discard for each one
it's pretty good I'll add a permanent discount
because that'll help out I've got a voucher unlocked even more I must be like steam sale
tarot cards let's go I'm over 100 gold I'm just that good right
planet glass stone planet planet no doubt four of a kind and a high card I mean
I'm just level everything up high card a joker card I don't need so we're gonna do a re-roll
a full house and a flush sure I'm quite happy there are only two dollars as well to buy like
upgrade the base of everything so I honestly don't mind
uh currently 18 joker well you are not gonna out oh you might outplay Todd
uh odd Todd your time is starting to look up I'm not gonna lie
50 chips 31 chips or 18 multiplier uh yeah I think it's time odd Todd
you have done fantastic we are appreciative of your services but you simply have just been
outplayed uh we will have you at the back I don't think it matters if you're at the back
thank you odd Todd for your service abstract joker welcome in we've not had you before so please
get ready to odd Todd is enabling your straights though have I just messed up put the pants on
the back how do you know where to put it in the bank I hope I didn't miss mess up there right when
we roll whoa why did you make that played face cards add odd Todd helps a lot rip run and before
we lose this because I got rid of we odd Todd 80 chips if hand contains a flush not that good
adds the number of times poker hands has been played
adds the number of times poker hands has been played to this run to the multi
that's fine a million
a million
endless is that yeah that's just I mean I knew we weren't gonna like infinitely win
well re-roll sure I'll take a full swing
Zach thank you for coming to member I appreciate it we are about to jump into the ASMR member
stream slightly late for it don't worry about it guys and we are about to redirect into none other
than a Zeridule who is doing ASMR so please do enjoy her uh to your full capacity straight flush
I don't want to go straight flushed off me little all right we can do one more
uh yes and yes to use well because we will utilize you okay next round
let's go all right what do you do select two cards give out the left card into the right
I would like to actually upgrade our doubles
because we're not really doing it
oh no
that may have been a mistake I'm gonna be honest that may have been a mistake
queen jack 10 no I don't have to flush at all
ooh I might mess up there make another steal ooh I like that idea select two cards that convert
the left card into the right one so two steals okay now I have to get riddles
I couldn't theory if we're going for a flush get rid of the jewel jack because we can jump over him
and vice versa
uh we can jump over the jack at any point so he's not really necessarily needed
or I could just get a steel jack you know your choice
oh no this is oh no this can't be I'm doing shit
wait am I a freaking idiot can I not jump allow straights to be made with gaps in one rank yeah
so I can still do the jump ace marison yes I'm about to lose this round I'm not even joking and I
I don't have any shred of hope I've completely balls this up and yeah I can still jump
yeah I knew I could still jump I've got a shortcut and 10
losing not good no not good at all but
we'll survive ish I don't even know what to play
hey the multiplier is so good but I have like nothing I can play
king queen 10 and then nothing
oh what do I do what do you recommend discard and fish for something better I'm gonna have to
right queen I can discard
I don't want to discard like these guys because they all give me a multiplier
oh but I'm gonna have to wait that plays a pair apparently oh yeah it does
I mean I only have four I can't throw it away
well I can't throw away that's what I'm gonna do I need to go for a flush
oh
king queen jack 10 9 8 oh
all right we're gonna have to just go for double vase 2 9
I mean
my luck is perishing guys I've used all my luck the game really said go redirect into
a zero right now I mean it's not too bad you're right it's not too bad let's give a shot what's
going on here
no I've not got it
I mean I can do a full house here but I've not got it
oh I think it's ogre won't be a lose if you redirect or should I just redirect
and end the stream and be like oh I won by the way wink wink
this scaling and endless most is insane
ah well we'll just play what we've got I know
yeah now we've already lost the first endless holy crap right six five four three and I can't
do anything wow that got like hard out in nowhere like so hard right we're just gonna
we're not gonna win so there's no point in like trying to freaking go nuts with the math behind
the game we don't have it right king jack 10 9 8 okay well don't have an 8 so we'll roll for an 8
we'll roll for an 8 yeah king jack 10 9 8 that's the best we can do with both clubs
no biggie we tried we tried our besties that wasn't bad that got insanely hard though like
instantly insanely hard I am very interested in trying to win with all the other decks though
pardon me sorry oh we unlocked a few things when I run without playing four of a kind oops
well considering I didn't get it why would you give me that as a card when I run without playing a
flush I mean that's really not that hard and then when I run copies the ability of the joker to the
right oh that would be a very interesting card nebula deck unlocked when um start run with the
telescope voucher and one consumable slot tell celestial pack always contain a planet card for
your most played poker hand wow that's an interesting element redeem at least 10 voucher cards in one
run all cards and packs are 50 off I thought that when I saw that I popped up on the side
um planet cards in your consumable area give 1.5 multi for this one
use a total of 25 planet cards from any pack I use 33 in that run flow
use a total of 25 tarot cards from any arena spectral cards may appear in any of the oh so
it's like bonus cards now I like that I love games that like level up and get easier or unlock more
unique stuff as time goes on like that's why I really like binding of Isaac three times multi on
final hand of a round play 200 hands well there it is balatro not to be diffused with more pro
and okay okay let's make sure that Azura Dooley is online and then I will very quickly swap my
microphone over and we will put up for cheeky ASMR segue member stream oh no my uh my appeal
was rejected for my coughing with no hands ASMR oh no I'm so surprised what do you mean I was being
so cheeky what do you mean I was being such a cheeky cheekerton quite literally get my cheeks out
um right let's check my Azura Dooley live and I'm definitely redirecting into her Azura is doing
ASMR so you'll be given complete bliss and love nothing but good vibes I'm sure it customization
redirect I can confirm I'm redirecting into none other than Azura Dooley and is she live
she's not hmm
when's the member stream right now when I redirect into Azura I'm literally gonna swap
my microphones around and make sure I'm on my ASMR I mean if you really want to have that
a
yeah yeah you like that let's see it's my arena
see it's not it's not it's not set up
one more run literally 90 for give her a few minutes yes I will wait until Azura goes live
as far as I'm aware all is good and she's not canceling this room
I mean she's online on the discord so
wait what bit of battle did you enjoy the most since the experience is fresh what did I enjoy the most
I think I enjoy discovering new cards and seeing how they all interact like that that new
straight mechanic being like oh you can skip a straight I'm like what do you mean you can skip
that's crazy like that was very fun to discover and you guys like telling me like what you think
is the best play and then like I'll say like oh actually I felt like that Joker card you know
we can do this we can do that and I quite like that I like the input I can do in this kind of game
as well like I like when you guys can like tell me what to do and be like right we're in this
together like it's us against the game you know it's not like it's not just me playing the game
it's like all of us are like come on like as I said we would definitely be kicked out the casino
by now because it's just me holding cards and then looking you all in the eyes like yeah
does everyone agree and then everyone gives me a nod and then I play it like we'd be kicked out so
quick so quick
why did you give me a hundred for that
ask ask terex why did you give me a hundred for that
gen 3 confirmed steady on steady on two designs confirmed for gen two what thank you very much
for that tip ask terex I appreciate it that's a big tip for literally well because I won in poker
in virtual poker because it was fun well I'm glad you guys had fun that's so much fun I
please do not be surprised if you see this game pop up again and I will most likely play it when
my dad visits because I can you know do like a four hour stream of it and you know we can all
hold my hand during the game thank you casino girl oh my god did you guys see that casino
japanese vtuber um I'm gonna find the video and literally post it in chat I kid you not casino
vtuber showcase look at this video and tell me this isn't that shit insane is this video was so
impactful I have yet to forget about it um some of you might recognize it because they got recommended
actually that reminds me nari wanted me to do a model showcase and she hasn't told me what she
wants me to make of the models which I should have a wee look at that I put a link in chat right now
haha four hours no way it's been six hours oh my god I was supposed to like be finished my eighth
of ASMR by now um yes you might recognize that showcase because it did not leave my head
we could see mama's brain expanding in real time yeah her hypnosis powers only grow stronger with
time oh thank you phoenix for the tip I'm getting so big brains
that can you tell in my voice when I'm thinking but yes if anyone's
wanting a casino girl honestly I quite like moxie's design from what's her what's that
franchise called oh my god we're claptrap and everything borderlands moxie borderlands
I preferred moxie's borderlands what design was it moxie borderlands three design question mark
was that the one I like the most
I honestly wouldn't mind a cute hat on someone
I'm down for a cute hat on someone I don't know who but someone
my delay is bad enough I watched the whole video before she mentioned it in the video oh no
I don't know why some of my streams have been on lowly uh on high normal latency and I've had to
manually put it back to low latency so there isn't a delay
right now I'm playing borderlands three I'm gonna uh for my birthday in October
I'm gonna see if I can wrangle some v-tubers to play borderlands two campaign with me
uh I'd like to do that for me birthday um problem is endurance streamers although saying that she
be done an endurance stream and so has Azura um
uh I might have made a new a new friend a new um
what do you call it when it's a professional relationship like because we both work in the
same job is that the terminology I may have made a new thingy it might be interesting possibly I
could grab one chick from a v-tuber agency in different agencies and do a borderlands thing
and it'll be like a four-way agency collab oh wow but you know only with people I vibe with because
yeah uh business part yeah business relationship yeah that's pretty much my man and
my main fact in the girls are endurance streaming we are so back literally I was so surprised Azura
did like insane on a stardew valley apparently she has like thousands of hours in it and I'm like
the game I have the most hours in is black ops one and then black ops two and then probably
overwatch and then dead by daylight and then it just kind of gets scattered around the place from
the 4k on stardew is she like a hundred percent of that stuff I think Isaac has most I think I
uh I cleared like I think I'm just shy of 500 hours in Isaac how many hours in dead by daylight
I was a very early player of dead by daylight I've probably got 1.5 thousand hours in dead by
daylight I was an early dead by daylight player I am not familiar with anything do not ask me the
question of anything uh in the recent updates I was gone a long time ago in that game um
wait did I say the number right yeah I probably got like 4,000 in cards and then overwatch would be
like 2,000 dead by daylight 1,000.5 like oh when I get into a game I get into a game like I'm only
at 700 just watch vods in two times speed yeah that's how you keep up with my content I was like
how am I supposed to keep up with your content if Azura has done a stardew stream into the 12 hour
mark of the day she she would actually have you beaten off well if youtube would fix their
vod issue then I'd be streaming a heck of a lot longer 4k and black ops one uh yeah most likely
on that one alone um I was very isolated as a child and played black ops one all day long
and I was having problems like going to school and all that had issues oh boo I'm gonna eat my
my protein ball so my stomach isn't rumbling too much during the ASMR um
2k and rims world ooh what's your guys' biggest game I have a next two weeks off of vacation
might be able to catch up with Tony's vods by then good luck
pretty strong you feel hot oh well we're in the good times now we flin don't worry about
yeah I'm basically used to sit and play xbox all day because um my parents were like super
understanding with the whole school situation um and having issues so I just kind of got left
to my xbox and that's why I play a lot of xbox games dominions what's dominions five dominions
five I haven't even heard of dominions one what kind of underground games are you guys playing
mama and papa cuttles are best yeah
mm-hmm oh this tastes awful I regret buying it
this protein peanut butter ball is shit I cast mend but crack it's that bad
probably dead by daylight with 3000 black ops mentioned one on five
oh no that's not one with five
do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do
not one 7k and destiny
yeah damn did you play kod zombie no I was terrified of kod zombies I still am I find it terrifying
I wish there was an end the reason why I thoroughly enjoyed college or a ghost alien mode is because
there was an end you can you can either win the game mode or you can die to the
aliens in the game mode which is why I adored it had an end games that are like
infinite replayability but doesn't give you some sort of closure or ending I
didn't like it so when like cod zombies keeps going that's not really for me
although I'm sure there's a new zombie game out that's supposed to rival cod
zombies kind of game mode completely forgotten the name of the game though
20k hours in world of warcraft yeah damn your ERP and in Goldshire a little
too much are you not I moved from game to game a lot 500 is probably on the
highest an elite elite sniper oh I wouldn't mind playing warhammer 2 I want
to see if there's any v-tubers that play warhammer 2 if it's the game I'm
thinking about and I used to play the healer in it and heal and you give
everyone heels and you go yeah that's me because it was like you use your voice
to heal everyone for me it's path of exile 3 hours high pixel sky block you
guys are teaching me names of games I've never heard of elite dangerous a space
similar I would not have learned how to code and I would not have a job right
now if it wasn't for gmod imagine not learning to code on neopets can't
relate html 5 all the way hi pixels a minecraft servers are you doing minecraft
team little minecraft clear you we are getting a minecraft server at some point
me and the girl me and the boys where is Azure are you live yet darling are you
okay I'm about to DM and be like you're a darling is everything okay do you need
me to come up you may come here who's maybe some microphone issues I wouldn't
be surprised if her 3d always acting up hmm wait she's 20 minutes late hold on
a minute hold on a minute where's my israeli send her a cheeky message where
are you zero is everything okay question mark I am waiting to read in to you with
enthusiasm do you know how hard it is to hold back and not say I want to read her
womb every time I'm like I want to read into you is there a did you listen to
your own 3d monitor and got overpowered by her sultry voice one quick more
about your run you are insane honestly I'll do it don't think I won't do it if
there comes back and is like oh my god I can't do it okay I can't eat this peanut
butter anymore it's actually broken she gave me the book do a challenge run as
we're just went live oh okay she's not gonna see that message I'm gonna spit
this out who wants some chewed up peanut butter ball oh she is up oh she's
got a loading screen she's got a loading screen I can see her in the bath tub
rubber dub dub I can see her in the bath tub okay okay right my little
reeflings I am going to send you to none other than a zero delay the goat goddess
of fertility of the lands of earth itself and I am going to take a very
quick five-minute break and far unironically because I got big fart
brewing on my guts and and then we're gonna build from some very late but
intimate ASMR member stream I will join and literally like give me five minutes
can you swap around the microphone and okay please enjoy sir thank you for
letting me turn this into a secret endurance stream when I only had the
inclination I was only gonna play for two hours but I can't help myself because
the game was so good okay the storm thank you for coming I'm a member bye bye
please enjoy sir lots of love I give you kiss me I kiss you and give you peanut
butter kisses and and I will see you incredibly shortly because I am a bit
to bit of the members team okay oh I just coughed a bit of food out that's
disgusting that's what happens when you talk with food in your mouth comes flying
at your mouth I was a really embarrassed and okay don't do that again like it
happens up for corner members oh okay bye bye we flings out I do ASMR like
right now okay give me one second